Easy.
MonkaW
Mit der Sound, top.
Aber Windows weiß man ja nie, ob die nicht irgendwas umgestellt haben.
Habt ihr übrigens auch gelesen, Windows 25 H2 ist angeblich total kaputt.
Gut, dass ich Windows 25 H2 hab.
Microsoft wipecoded einfach zu viel von ihrem ganzen Mist.
Waren wir mal die VM an und installieren Updates.
Das schadet doch nichts.
Und dann wieder rebooted.
ja anscheinend ist es aber jetzt ja aber anscheinend ist es nicht einfach nur kaputt
sondern richtig kaputt so dass es gab jetzt letztens ein problem habe ich gelesen dass
windows sich nicht mehr richtig ausschalten lässt oder sowas habe ich den news gelesen
windows lässt sich nicht mehr runterfahren
da gab es doch ein problem beim shutdown
jetzt ging doch nicht mehr da gab es doch irgendeinen
google google
das ist eine news
selbst pcs können nach update nicht herunter gefahren werden
ich glaube bis da hat er tatsächlich noch fehlerfreier funktioniert
und sein computer plötzlich nicht mehr ausschalten
Warum kriege ich hier eine Katze angezeigt?
Ach hier, Iga Chat Cat.
Es ist laufend was Neues.
Will der Igel, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
das wird vom titel her gucken wir das schon mal nicht an
So.
du benutzt windows server 2022 für den gaming warum das denn uns das überhaupt
gescheit sie ist damit direkt x und sachen aus
das ist doch bestimmt riesenakt auf dem windows server und linux musste halt
gucken mittlerweile funktioniert das ja
erstaunlich gut was halt nicht funktioniert ist wenn du irgendwelche
sachen mit kölner level anti cheat und sowas spielen willst
Dann hast du...
Pech bei vielen Spielen.
Was ist das für ein Emote, Alter?
Gibt es den überhaupt noch?
Okay, aus dem
gesehen, ja, gut. Ich weiß,
früher war es problematisch, auf dem Server
Windows spielen zu wollen, weil da
viele Sachen nicht gingen. Oh, vielleicht,
ach, man weiß ja mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Wer ist Kellner? Okay.
Ach, whatever.
Ich hab gedacht, er ist in Dubai und hat
seine Millionen oder was
er da irgendwann mal erzählt hat.
Mit den Fake-Geldscheinen.
So.
Aber hier mal
auf und jetzt erstmal Updates machen.
Einmal die Woche Update schaden nicht.
Arch, by the way.
Zack.
Ich habe übrigens was programmiert die letzte Woche über.
Das kann ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen.
Weil ich es gestern Abend kaputt gemacht habe und nur diesen Stand eingecheckt habe.
Ich habe mir ein Tool programmiert, was Domain-Ablaufzeiten anzeigt.
Da basteln wir heute vielleicht ein bisschen im Stream dran weiter.
Weil ich will das auch noch per Prometheus-Metrik bereitstellen.
Aktuell malt das mir nur eine schöne Tabelle, Command-Line-mäßig.
Max, was machst du, wenn die 4-Tage-Woche verboten wird?
Die 4-Tage-Woche wird nicht verboten.
Es gibt kein Recht mehr drauf, dass du sagen kannst, ey, ich will das machen.
Und der Arbeitgeber dann nur sagen kann, aktuell sprechen dringende betriebliche Gründe dagegen.
Das geht nicht und dann muss er ja Abhilfe schaffen.
Also selbst wenn, kann man sich da immer noch komplett drauf verständigen, beidseitig, dass man das machen will.
Zumal es bei mir eh schon im Vertrag drin steht und das garantiert nicht für Sachen gilt, die schon, ähm, oder gelten,
oder es wird zumindest rechtlich schwierig, das für Sachen rückwirkend dann nicht mehr zu wollen und sowas.
Aber da sehe ich für mich jetzt keine Probleme.
Das habe ich übrigens, das habe ich auch gelesen, ja.
Ja, ja, das habe ich auch gelesen.
Ein weiterer Grund, ich sage ja schon die ganze Zeit, dass ich keinen BitLocker verwende.
Also, BitLocker war bei mir ab dem Zeitpunkt unten durch, wo ich damals, als es neu war, gelesen habe, dass man sein Passwort restoren kann.
So, und jede Verschlüsselung mit einem Passwortrestore, ohne dass man das Passwort weiß, ist halt für den Arsch.
Gute Verschlüsselung heißt Passwort weg, Daten weg, fertig.
Daten noch da, aber nicht mehr lesbar.
Aber selbst das, die müssen ja dann Abhilfe schaffen, ne?
Also so ist es ja aktuell.
Also wenn du sagst, ich würde gerne Teilzeit arbeiten und ein Arbeitgeber sagt, nee.
Wobei, das kann sein, dass das erste Ab- und Betrieb von zehn Mitarbeitern gilt oder so, keine Ahnung genau.
Aber zumindest bei Größeren ist es so, da können die sagen, ja, da sprechen wichtige betriebliche Gründe dagegen.
Aber dann müssen die die abschaffen und in einem halben Jahr, glaube ich, kannst du dann wieder sagen,
Ich will Teilzeiten dann wirklich abgeschafft haben.
Office-Pflicht für zwei.
Ich habe von meinem alten Arbeitgeber gehört, ihr wisst ja, eines der größten Knackpunkte bei mir war ja,
unter anderem bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber, dass ich gesagt habe, ich habe keinen Bock mehr drauf,
weil die wieder angefangen haben mit Präsenz im Office und sowas, wo ich gesagt habe,
Alter, ich kriege da viel besser und mehr Sachen daheim geschafft und ich muss mich nicht mit der scheiß Bahn rumschlagen.
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
So, und jetzt ist ja das Witzige gerade, ich könnte quasi jetzt die ganze Woche Homeoffice machen, ab und zu, ach, müsste man kommen, aber ich bin aktuell fast jeden Tag in Frankfurt, freiwillig, ich bin bescheuert eigentlich, aber das lenkt mich ab und deswegen fahre ich nach Frankfurt.
Aber was ich jetzt, worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte, ich habe von meinem alten Arbeitgeber gehört, die sind auch erst von einem Tag die Woche Präsenz zu zwei Tagen die Woche Präsenz und jetzt haben sie angefangen drei Tage die Woche Präsenz.
und das haben sie folgendermaßen begründet
also sie haben es gar nicht begründet
sie haben es gar nicht begründet
sie haben sich eine Fake-Story ausgedacht
bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
um den Leuten
aufs Auge zu drücken
ihr müsst wieder drei Tage ins Office kommen
und was sie gesagt haben ist folgendes
der Chef hat gesagt, Leute
ihr müsst wieder drei Tage die Woche
ins Büro kommen, weil letztens
wäre angeblich der Vorstand durch die Büros
gelaufen und das sah so leer aus und das hat
denen nicht gefallen.
Und das war die Begründung für
jetzt sollen sie wieder drei Tage die Woche hinkommen.
Also das ist, also ich
gehe ganz stark davon aus, das ist eine Fake-Story.
Das ist nie passiert.
Und selbst wenn es passiert ist,
heißt es ja nicht, dass man das machen muss.
Also, das ist total
an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Die wollten das und haben sich irgendwas
aus den Fingern gesaugt, um es den Leuten zu erklären.
Du hattest mal gezeigt in einem Stream, wie du in Go eine Config konfigurierbar machen
würdest.
Welcher Stream war das?
War das mit Vue und dann als Single File und dann per Webserver bereitstellen?
Config konfigurierbar?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was du meinst.
meinst du, dass man sich die
seine
Commandline-Arguments quasi
entweder über Commandline
über
Environment-Variablen
oder Config holen kann?
Ja, und
Single-File, das habe ich tatsächlich
gemacht in Go.
Single-File und dann
eine
das war Svelte,
das war's welt geht wir haben 12 kitten single page app gebaut die haben wir in
embedded in unserem binary das haben wir gemacht aber welcher stream das war weiß
ich nicht mehr vielleicht vielleicht war das auch in den stream wo ich etwas
geleakt habe und danach wieder gelöscht habe
Ja, ja, das habe ich mitbekommen, habe ich gerade schon was dazu gesagt.
Es geht darum, dass du nicht mehr das Recht hast, wie jetzt, dass du sagen kannst, ich will Teilzeit arbeiten.
Dein Arbeitgeber kann sagen, es sprechen dringende betriebliche Gründe dagegen, aber dann muss er es abschaffen.
freiwillig einigen
mit deinem Arbeitgeber kannst du dich nach wie vor.
Aber ich finde das an sich
auch schon total bescheuert.
Also mal grundsätzlich gesagt.
Wir sind frei, was
Vertragsgestaltung angeht. Also wenn ich nur
50% arbeiten will, mein Arbeitgeber sagt,
passt, dann ist das kein Problem.
Oh ne, hör mal bloß auf.
Ich weiß jetzt, ich weiß jetzt auch relativ, relativ sicher von wo das kam.
Schon überlegt, ob ich da mal was hinschreiben soll, aber weiß drauf.
Bei dem Shop.
Nee, nee, nee, hat er nicht.
Aber es kann eigentlich nur eine Sache sein.
überlege gerade wie ich eine einfache ui mache um paar sachen zu konfigurieren für
ein programm und dachte das wäre dafür also quasi dass es eine
config fall gibt und diese singt mit der webview
also sowas habe ich noch nicht gemacht
danke schön für den sub
subscriber
ach ich hab das gelöschte gutes
ich mich jetzt nicht weiter mit beschäftigen
also meine vermutung ist meine vermutung
ich habe bei einem shop was bestellt relativ was eindeutiges also nix nix
nichts hier was eindeutiges wenn man bei meinen stream vorher geguckt hat weil
ich darüber geredet habe im stream dass ich mir das bestellen will da gibt es
nicht so viele die sich das bestellen und auch max heißen und das wird
wahrscheinlich so ein ganz kleiner shop sein mit zwei drei leuten und die haben
gesehen und natürlich wissen sie dann auch die lieferadresse das ist meine
vermutung und das ist das einzige was passt
so updates
was das neuer key
So, jetzt mal gucken, ob es neue Jetbrains Sachen gibt.
Alles updaten, zack.
Yes, yes.
Reboot, nee noch nicht.
Erstmal update abwarten.
alt
ja alt bin ich eh, aber das hat damit nichts zu tun
ich war die letzten Wochen tatsächlich immer mal
ganz kurz davor wieder ein Video zu machen
ich wollte ja mal ein Video machen was los ist
aber eigentlich will ich da gar nicht so im großen
Stil drüber reden so
weil auf Youtube ist natürlich
schon mal noch ein bisschen
größere Reichweite als auf Twitch
jetzt
und dann schreiben wieder Leute irgendwie dummes Zeug drunter
und ne
Max, wie ist es eigentlich mit AI bei dir auf der Arbeit?
Bei uns hypen es alle, aber keiner bekommt eine Lizenz oder Talks und so weiter.
Also bei uns ist es so, wir haben mehrere Sachen zur Auswahl bei uns.
Wir haben einmal einen internen Chat, der kommt, das ist wahrscheinlich GPT-5 oder sowas,
der kommt von Azure, das haben sie sich da irgendwie gemietet.
Da kann man sich quasi irgendwie Chat-GPT bei Azure mieten, als eigene Instanz.
Die haben sie trainiert mit allen internen Wikis und Ticketsystemen und sonst was.
Das heißt, du kannst dann in dem Chat fragen, ey, sag mir mal, da gab es doch eine News vor 5 Monaten, wann die nächste Abteilungsversammlung ist.
Und dann kann dir das der Chat beantworten.
Der kann dir auch andere Sachen beantworten.
Da ist GPT-5 drunter oder Gemini 2.5 Flash, glaube ich.
Die zwei Sachen zur Auswahl.
Dann kannst du fragen, wie mache ich in Java oder in Go das und das.
Das ist dann ganz okay.
Aber was eigentlich viel besser ist, wir haben verschiedene Projekte bei Google in der Cloud.
Und da kann man mit den Projekt-Keys Gemini 3 oder Gemini 3, was ist denn das aktuelle 3?
Kannst du zumindest das
Visual Studio Code Gemini Plugin
Verwenden und das mit deinem Projekt
Anmelden
Und dann hast du eigentlich
Unlimited
Also Unlimited nicht
Du musst es nicht bezahlen
Die Versicherung bezahlt
Was geht
Zur Zeit geht nix
Ich bin froh
Dass bei mir privat alles so weit geht
dass ich im Kopf wieder halbwegs
frei bin
mich auf
angenehme Sachen zu konzentrieren
so
Updates sind durch
ja so sieht das bei uns auf der Arbeit aus
also wir sind ganz gut dabei
was AI angeht könnte natürlich noch
deutlich nicer sein
zum Beispiel
mit
wobei, also ich verstehe schon,
warum sie es nicht machen. Also ich wollte sagen,
ich würde auch gerne hier
Opus 4.5 oder irgendwas benutzen können.
Aber
da haben sie halt das Problem
mit, wohin gehen die Daten und was
passieren damit. Das verstehe ich schon soweit.
Wie viele arbeiten bei euch in der
IT? Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist viel, auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß,
dass wir die größte Abteilung sind.
Also das ist
im 100er Bereich, also keine Ahnung.
Oder vielleicht sogar im
4-stelligen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Theoretisch müsste ich das wissen.
Es gibt da so eine Übersichtspräsentation für
Leute, die neu sind.
Die habe ich mir auch angeguckt, als ich neu war, habe ich aber schon alles
wieder verdrängt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viel das sind.
denkst du du wirst dieses jahr eine katze adoptieren ich würde ja prinzipiell gerne
aber ich bin also ich ich ich zögere mir eine katze wieder zu holen weil ich hatte
jetzt ja in den letzten jahren drei stück die waren alle schon alt und die haben alle
nicht so lange gelebt nur ein paar jahre die eine tat die eine sogar unter einem unter einem
Und ich habe doch hier ein Video gemacht.
Warum kann man das nicht direkt auf YouTube aufmachen?
Und die sind ja alle drei gestorben, weil halt alt.
Und gesundheitliche Probleme, die Katzen.
Und das nimmt einen schon immer sehr mit.
Und deswegen bin ich mir echt am überlegen, ob ich mir...
Hallo Leute, hier ist der...
Jaja, ob ich mir nochmal eine holen soll.
Ist sie nicht niedlich?
Ja, Chico.
Das ist Chico.
Das ist hier...
Moment.
Das hier ist Original Cats FPS.
Und dann haben wir hier...
Die hatte ich leider nicht so lange.
Die hatte ich bloß ein Dreivierteljahr oder so.
Die hatte schlimme Erkrankungen.
Die war auch ein bisschen chonker hier.
Und die hat immer gerne...
Die hat immer gerne auf dem Fernseher...
Ihr habt es ja gerade gesehen.
Die hat immer gerne auf dem Fernseher irgendwelche Vögel und so an sich angeguckt.
Wieso holst du nicht eine junge Katze?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich mag alte Katzen irgendwie.
Da weiß man auch schon, was man kriegt.
Die ist auch schon mal hoch zum Fernseher gegangen
und hat geguckt, wo die Vögel da drin sind.
Guck.
Die hat sich immer so Zeugs hier angeguckt.
Das fand die super spannend im Fernsehen.
Die hat da vorgesetzt und konnte sich in einem halben Tag
irgendwelche Eichhörnchen oder sonst was angucken.
Guck, die fand das super spannend.
Und manchmal hat die auch ganz komische Geräusche gemacht
vom Fernseher.
Ich versuche es mal nachzumachen.
Die war super aufgeregt
vor dem Fernseher.
Ah ja.
Da ist Chico unter meinem Hemd.
Hallo, Chico.
Chico ist übrigens auch die, die hier unten ist.
Das scheint da sehr spannend drunter zu sein.
Vielleicht will die auch Verstecken spielen.
Du siehst mich auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich bin versteckt.
Du kannst mich gar nicht sehen.
und komplett unsichtbar, oder?
Seht ihr hier eine Katze? Also ich nicht.
Jo.
War sie nicht niedlich.
Plinsel, Plinsel.
Alter, war ich da noch dick?
Guck mal meinen Arm an, ey.
WTF?
Guck mal meinen dicken Arm an.
Ja gut, vor vier Jahren, da war ich noch 25 Kilo fetter.
Sieht man direkt, ey.
Geschnatter, ja, sowas.
ich denn es sagt ich arbeite im öffentlichen dienst der kommunalverwaltung da habe ich
letztens auf reddit was gelesen dass es da leute gibt die sich zur mittagspause oder
zum mittag in ihrem büro einschließen und um dort zu pennen ist das bei euch auch so
wir haben ca 53 mitarbeiter die nur datenmanagement machen wie viele
ITler fühlen sich für die angemessen an, wenn du an der Versicherung denkst, die ja hauptsächlich das gleiche machen.
Oh, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe wirklich, das kommt ja auch ein bisschen darauf an, wie viele Services ihr habt und sonst was.
Wenn es im Prinzip, wenn diese 350 Mitarbeiter nur zwei, drei verschiedene Services benutzen, die auf, keine Ahnung,
auf drei Servern laufen,
was ja durchaus sein kann,
dann brauchst du dafür nicht viel.
Habt ihr aber, keine Ahnung,
150 verschiedene Services,
dann sieht es schon mal anders aus.
Das kann man schlecht sagen.
Ich bin bei solchen Fragen
auch schlecht im Schätzen.
such dir gerade leute bei deinem arbeitgeber ja aber ich kann nicht die ich kann es nicht
zeigen und sleek ja machen wir wir suchen gerade einen junior storage admin glaube ich
und ein paar anderen.
Es sind knapp
drei Seiten, sind voll,
was IT angeht. Aber bei uns
stehen in der IT-Stellenanzeige
stehen dann auch irgendwelche
Innovationsmanager
oder so komisches
Zeug, keine Ahnung. Hat ja mit
IT nicht wirklich was zu tun, aber steht trotzdem in der Kategorie
drin.
Trennst du eigentlich
dein Homeoffice Setup und Streaming Gaming Setup? Ne, mach ich nicht mehr. Am Anfang
habe ich das so gemacht, also als ich neu war bei dem Arbeitgeber, da habe ich mein
Arbeitsnotebook verwendet, habe ich da einfach meine Tastatur angeschlossen, Monitor angeschlossen,
Maus angeschlossen, per VPN eingeloggt, da habe ich das mit dem Notebook gemacht. Aber
ganz ehrlich, das ist mir
zu viel Act. Ich arbeite
jetzt eigentlich zu 99%
über Shitrix.
Hier direkt am Rechner.
Ich hab doch hier auch
diesen Mist, guck hier, diesen Mist hier installiert.
Citrix Workspace.
Ich logg mich dann einfach ein
über den Browser, mach
5-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Na gut, ganz so viel ist es nicht, aber wir müssen
mittlerweile so oft und dreifach
und vierfach Passwörter eingeben. Das ist nicht mehr normal.
Ich sage dann immer, Spaß ist Fünf-Faktor-Authentifizierung mittlerweile.
Und dann geht mein Citrix-Workspace auf und ich arbeite da drüber.
Ja, das hat ein bisschen Lack. Das dürft ihr. Ja klar, warum nicht?
Und dann logge ich mich bei Citrix ein und arbeite da drüber.
Aber es hat ein bisschen Lack, minimales Lack.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so snappy, wie wenn du hier lokal irgendwie bist.
Und bei mir ist es ja vor allem noch ein bisschen mehr Lack, weil...
Ups, was jetzt?
Ah, es backt wieder rum.
Es ist sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Lack, weil ich mache das so.
Also, ich logge mich per Zytrix ein.
Dann logge ich mich auf meine Linux-Admin-Kiste ein.
und mache dann dort über X-Forwarding
ein Terminal auf.
Weil ich kriege halt nur Windows auf der Arbeit.
Und das Terminal mache ich dann in Fullscreen
und versuche möglichst zu vergessen,
dass Windows da drum herum läuft.
Ist das dieses Poem-Ding wie Proxmox?
Nee, Citrix ist diese, wie nennt man das?
VDI oder sowas?
Virtual Desktop Info...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Da kriegst du halt eine virtuelle Desktop-Kiste.
Die sind aber gar nicht schlecht ausgerüstet bei uns.
Man hat sogar eine Grafikkarte da durchgereicht.
In die VM.
Also in diesen virtuellen Desktop.
Eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte bekommst du durchgereicht.
Also das fühlt sich gar nicht so mies an.
Das ist schon ganz okay.
Eins der Anwendungen geht bei uns, glaube ich, nicht.
Weil es ist natürlich auch Copy-Paste und sowas deaktiviert.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht hier was reinpasten in Citrix,
beziehungsweise nichts aus Citrix rauspasten.
Wobei man da tricksen kann.
Man kann Screenshot machen und dann OCR-Erkennung machen.
Das funzt, kriegt man Sachen raus.
Man kann auch einfach sich ein Makro programmieren, was die Sachen dann per Tastatur eintippt.
Das geht auch.
Also man kann das umgehen, wenn man da technisch versiert ist.
Aber wozu?
Das funzt bei uns.
Ich habe mir auch einen zweiten Schreibtisch gekauft.
Aber nicht für Homeoffice.
sondern ich mache ich habe doch hier ab und zu mal bastel streams gemacht hier
wartet mal wo blotts punkt tv ja wir haben doch mal hier was dann
weizung oder so
ja wir hatten doch ihr bastel stream cook so und dieses zeug das was ihr seht das
ist super behelfsmäßige setup ja ich habe mir so ganz alten tisch einen hohen
Tisch, dass man da ordentlich im Stehen dran basteln kann,
aus der
Garage geholt hier
und hab hier neben
mein Ringlight dran gemacht mit einer Kamera
in der Mitte, dass ich das überhaupt aufnehmen kann.
Das ist ein super behilfsmäßiges Setup.
Das will ich jetzt verbessern.
Ich hab mir einen billigen
Schreibtisch bestellt, einen billigen, höhenverstellbaren
Schreibtisch. Also ich glaub 100 Euro.
Das ist wirklich ein ganz billiges Ding.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, es wurscht. Ja, ich will ja
daran nicht arbeiten, sondern ab zum bisschen basteln.
Dafür tut das schon. Und
den werde ich dann, das hier kommt weg,
dafür werde ich den Schreibtisch hier nebenhin stellen.
Dann habe ich quasi so über die Ecke
zwei Tische, hier mein Arbeitstisch.
Dann
quasi dran an der Wand den anderen Tisch.
Und dann habe ich endlich Platz.
Ihr seht ja wie, ihr seht hier wirklich
den kompletten Tisch. Hier vorne sind vielleicht noch
1, 2 Zentimeter, 1 Zentimeter.
Also das ist wirklich ja komplett
Da hast du kaum Platz
Übrigens die nice Vera
Joker Schlüssel
Beste
Wer hat der weiß
Dass die nice sind
Chat
Haben wir hier noch mehr Vera Joker Enjoyer
Wann nächstes
Ich war die letzten paar Wochen so kurz
Davor dass ich mal ein Video mache mit
was los ist
für YouTube auch.
Ich könnte
ein übelst krasses Clickbait-Video
machen. Ich könnte in den Titel schreiben
Ich musste in die Psychiatrie.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Und dann
gibt es Klicks.
Es ist nicht
gelogen, Leute. Es ist nicht gelogen.
Wird bei euch starkes Mikro-Management zelebriert?
Ne, komplett das Gegenteil.
Der Chef lässt dann eigentlich komplett machen, steht aber immer für Unterstützung bereit, kurzfristig.
Also das muss man wirklich sagen, bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber, das ist ein riesen Unterschied, was die Führungskräfte angeht zum alten.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber war das so, es war gefühlt,
also wer bei 3 nicht auf dem Baum war, wenn sie mal wieder einen neuen Teamleiter gesucht haben,
wurde es, egal ob er sich geeignet hat, ob er darauf vorbereitet war, ob er Bock hatte oder nicht.
So ungefähr war das beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Beim neuen ist das tatsächlich so eine Karrierelaufbahn in dem Sinne.
Also du kannst sagen, ich würde das gerne machen.
dann kannst du Vorbereitungskurse machen,
dann kannst du ein bisschen üben,
dann kannst du dir auch immer überlegen,
ah ne, will ich dann doch nicht machen und sowas.
Viel besser und das merkt man den Leuten dann ohne Scheiß.
Die Führungskräfte dort sind durch die Bank weg
einfach viel besser als beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Das heißt nicht, dass die Leute sich beim alten
nicht wirklich teilweise Mühe gegeben haben,
teilweise auch überhaupt nicht,
aber insgesamt sind die einfach viel besser
und das liegt auch bestimmt an der Vorbereitung
und an der Auswahl der Leute.
Versicherung
Ich war da
Früher war ich bei einer Bank
Jetzt bin ich bei einer Versicherung
Das ist viel viel besser
Und da gibt es auch kein Mikro-Management
Mein Chef lässt mich in der Regel
Einfach machen
Ab und zu erzähle ich dem mal was so los ist
Und wenn es halt so Dinge gibt
Wo es Probleme gibt
Ja zum Beispiel
Nehmen wir mal eine Sache wo es jetzt Probleme gibt
Bei uns ist es so
Es gibt, also da ist ja, was Regularien angeht, ist ja sowohl Bank als auch Versicherung, ist ja riesig, super viel Regularien.
So, und da muss man teilweise, also wenn man Linux-Systeme betreut, gibt es Leute, die haben sich beispielsweise, ich versuche es mal so abstrakt wie möglich zu erklären,
gibt es Leute, die haben sich Vorgaben für Linux-Systeme ausgedacht.
So nach dem Motto, Root-Login muss disabled sein, oder sowas in der Richtung, ja, könnt ihr euch vorstellen.
Gut, Login muss disabled sein. Wer Grafana installiert, muss die Data Sources per HTTPS anbinden. Solche Geschichten stehen da drin. Da gibt es ganz viele solcher Vorgaben. Das Ding ist halt, Vorgaben an sich bringen ja nichts, wenn nicht kontrolliert wird, ob die eingehalten werden.
Deswegen gibt es bei uns ein selbstentwickeltes Tool.
Leute, dieses Tool ist wirklich richtig oldschool.
Das ist noch in Cornshell programmiert.
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Das war auch sogar schon vor meiner Zeit.
Cornshell.
Von David Corn, so so.
Für den Amiga gab es das.
Cornshell in der Version von 1988.
Also das ist noch in Cornshell
programmiert, dieses Tool, ja.
Gibt es da auch eine aktuelle
Version von?
Sieht man nicht.
Gibt es das auf GitHub mittlerweile?
Cornshell
latest release.
Okay, irgendjemand. Zumindest, das ist noch in
Cornshell programmiert. Und das ist eine riesige
Sammlung aus Skripten. Eigentlich ziemlich nice,
was die da alles quasi mit
Shell-Skripts auf die Beine gestellt haben.
Das ist quasi eine riesen Sammlung
aus Shell-Skripts,
die dann auf dem System gucken,
ob das, was in den Vorgaben drin steht,
auch eingehalten werden.
Zum Beispiel, ja, root-login muss
disabled sein. Da gibt es dann ein Skript drin,
sowas wie check-user-permissions.ksh.
das crept dann in der
ssh-config, ob rootlogin disabled
ist, ob sudo-sachen
eingerichtet sind und sowas.
Und da
haben wir gerade ein Problem, weil
dieses Checkscript, es läuft auf
allen Linux-Systemen, kannst dich auch nicht dagegen wehren,
dieses Checkscript
meckert gerade bei mir,
Server von mir an,
und zwar Grafana-Server,
meckert das an,
guckt aber nicht im richtigen Verzeichnis.
Der sagt, Grafana ist falsch eingerichtet, guckt aber nicht im richtigen Verzeichnis nach.
So, und ich habe jetzt schon ein paar Mal mit denen geredet und die wollen das auch anpassen, aber das dauert ein bisschen, bis das angepasst ist.
Und bei uns läuft das dann ab.
Also sobald dieser Scanner, dieses Tool was erkennt, was nicht richtlinienkonform ist, dann läuft ein Countdown los.
Oder ein Counter läuft dann hoch.
So, und sobald das über 45 Tage kommt, glaube ich, eskaliert das automatisch mit einem Ticket an deinen Chef.
Kommt das über 60 Tage, eskaliert es automatisch mit einem Ticket an deinen Abteilungsleiter.
Und so weiter und so weiter.
Ihr könnt es euch vorstellen.
Also du musst das einhalten.
Du hast keine Chance.
Du musst das einhalten.
Und noch schlimmer, noch schlimmer, Leute, noch schlimmer, wenn das erstmal an den Abteilungsleiter eskaliert wurde, dann kriegt jeder 0,1 Bonuszahlungen, also 10% Bonuszahlungen vom gesamten Team abgezogen.
für das Team, was quasi
Sicherheitsdinger nicht einhält.
10% vom Bonus kriegst du abgezogen
für jede über 60 Tage
Sicherheitsvorgabenverstoß.
Da kannst du dich sicherlich sehr
unbeliebt machen in deinem Team, wenn du das öfters
eskalieren lässt.
Also das ist ganz wichtig bei uns,
weil es gibt ja auch Regularien
und Behörden, die das kontrollieren und alles.
Das muss alles richtig sein.
Und ich hab ein System, das ist jetzt bei 42 Tagen.
Und das System ist richtig.
Aber dieses Checkskript, er kennt es nicht richtig.
Und bei solchen Sachen kann ich immer zu meinem Chef gehen und sagen,
hier, wir müssen da was machen oder wir brauchen da eine Sondergenehmigung oder sonst was.
Und dann geht das immer sehr zackig und der macht das.
Also das ist mega nice.
Führungskräfte dort sind echt top.
Können wir das schauen? Was ist das denn?
Kann ich mich trauen, das aufzumachen?
Der Titel von dem Video war doch gerade anders.
Hä?
Warum ich Windows endgültig sechstens...
Hat er den Titel...
Hat er den Titel gelöscht?
Hat er den Titel geändert?
Weil YouTube irgendwie da umspringt?
Linux ist endlich extrem einfach.
Ja, das können wir gucken.
Setze ein Hardlink vom falschen Verzeichnis hin das richtige.
Das frunzt nicht.
Okay, also, was das Skript macht ist,
es ist nicht direkt Grafana, aber
bleiben wir mal beim Beispiel Grafana.
Das guckt, ob ich in etc.grafana.grafana.conf das richtige gesetzt habe.
Aber das habe ich nicht gesetzt.
Der müsste in etc.grafana.grafana.de.
Bla bla bla Conf gucken.
Was er aber nicht macht, der guckt nur in der Main-Config.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen...
Ist nicht wirklich so, wie ich es jetzt gesagt habe, aber so...
So ist das gelagert, das Problem.
Wir müssen das anpassen.
Können wir gucken.
Moin.
Habe aufgrund und mit deiner Hilfe
2021 mit 25...
Ja, sehr gut. Ich war auch schon ein bisschen älter, als ich meine
Physiausbildung gemacht habe.
Wie alt war ich denn
1984 minus 2007 23 war ich da das fast so alt wie du jetzt weiterbildung
ID Projektleiter im Juni
voraussichtlich fertig. Ja, nice.
Gratz.
Hast du dir schon mal OpenClaw angeschaut?
Moment, Moment. Heißt das jetzt nicht
mittlerweile? Ne, jetzt heißt es
OpenClaw, ne? Es hieß
ClaughtBot.
Da hat sich aber Anthropic irgendwie drüber
aufgeregt.
Dann hieß es MoldBot
oder so. Und jetzt heißt es OpenClaw.
Ja, angeschaut in Videos.
ausprobiert noch nicht da muss ich mir wenn schon extra vm für installieren
du meinst dass ich 41 jetzt bin ja bin ich bin ich wir haben leider kein kein
im ort für old aber ich bin old
ob old haben
wann porsche das jetzt irgendwie ist das ist das überhaupt noch angesagt
heutzutage ist das ist das noch ein ziel was man heutzutage hat porsche porsche
zu fahren also ich war mein elektro fiat das
reicht
So, Updates haben wir gemacht.
Passt. Zack. Dann gucken
wir doch mal.
Äh, ich will kein
Porsche.
Da gucken wir doch mal, was auf GitHub so
trendet. Wir machen erstmal
diesen ganzen Kreml zu. Moment, was habe ich da noch offen
gehabt?
Microsoft macht Zeug
Okay
Das war jetzt sehr schlau, Max
Also, GitHub Trends
Was trendet denn auf GitHub so?
Weekly
Es ist wieder so kurz
Alter, GitHub fuckt mich in letzter Zeit auch ein bisschen ab
Warum sind die Trends
Bitteschön, jetzt nur noch 8 Stück
Früher waren es 20
Wenn ich jetzt hier auf eine Sprache gehe
Ja, zum Beispiel C Sharp oder so
Dann sind es glaube ich wieder 20
Oder 15 oder so
Also ganz ehrlich was geht hat da teilweise das ist vor micro das ist keine ahnung das haben die bestimmt vibe coded
Da ist es halt kann das halt mal passieren wenn man das vibe coded
Open klar hier da okay die sterne bei dem projekt gehen wir wirklich voll steil
Ich bin das witzig dass er das selbst vibe coded hat mit klopft
System prompts leak.
Collection of extract systems from
popular chatbots. Aha.
Okay. AI. AI.
AI. Make videos.
Das haben wir letztes Mal schon gesehen.
Page index.
Äh, AI.
Wenn man das hier liest. AI.
AI.
AI. Äh, AI.
IPTV
Free IPTV
Okay
Ja, sehe ich verkehrt
Okay, also sehe ich das richtig
Wir haben in den Trending Projekten
Genau eins, was nicht
AI ist
Okay, gucken wir mal
Falls ihr eine Idee
habt, welche Programmier...
Rust! Rust gucken wir.
Die Krustentiere.
Erstmal gucken wir mal bei Go.
HashiCorp Vault trendet.
Ingress Engine X trendet.
Moment, warum trendet Ingress Engine X?
Die haben das doch abgeschafft.
Oder auch nicht.
Hä? Ich denke, der ist retiring.
Genau.
Best effort maintenance
March 2026.
Was übrigens auch witzig ist,
Ingress Engine X
wird retired.
Engine X Ingress nicht.
Die Benahmung in dem Umfeld
ist auch teilweise echt dämlich.
Also lasst euch nicht verwirren.
Ingress Engine X und Engine X Ingress.
Ingress Engine X
ist der Ingress auf
Engine X Basis vom Kubernetes Projekt.
Engine X Ingress
ist der Ingress auf Engine X
Basis vom Engine X Projekt.
Alles klar?
Oh, das ist hier Leedspeak.
Was heißt das?
Was ist ein 9 in Leedspeak?
I?
S? Ist das ein S?
Where is he?
Ja, danke schön.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
Subscription.
Oder heißt das weiblich 49 in einer Stunde?
So.
AI.
Ja, Ulama ist pock.
Leute, ich bin jetzt von hier von
LM Studio
bin ich eigentlich für die Sachen
daheim umgestiegen komplett auf ulama das einzige für lm studie noch verwende
wenn ich schnell den schönen chat brauche lokal china chinesen zeug
das den namen passwort generator erstellt ist auch nicht schlecht redis
Open-Cost-Cobra-Stells. Ich benutze bei Go immer Kong als Command Line Parser.
Hier auch nicht so viel Spannendes drin.
Das ist ein nices Projekt. Hätte ich ein Solarpanel auf dem Dach, hätte ich das auch installiert.
Hab die GPU aus meinem Heimserver genommen. Von 56 Watt Eitelverbrauch auf 38 gesunken. Experiment GPU ist vorbei. Und was ist das Fazit des Experiments?
Bei Ulama lade ich die Modelle nicht manuell runter, sondern ich gebe die Hugging-Face-URL an. Kann man das damit auch machen?
Ansonsten ist es aber auch kein Problem.
Man kann die Modelle auch einfach runterladen.
Das ist ja nicht so, als hast du irgendwie 80 Modelle oder so, die du da verwenden willst.
Hast du die GPU jetzt rausgeschmissen und hast dir einen Mac Mini gekauft für AI?
Also ich bin gerade tatsächlich am überlegen, ob ich nicht Paperless mit AI mal ausprobiere.
Da kann es auch lahmlaufen, weil die Metadatenerkennung und Sachen für Paperless,
wenn das einmal eine Viertelstunde braucht, nach einem Scan ist auch nicht wild.
Übrigens, mein Nass ist da, by the way.
Ich habe mir doch hier so ein Ding bestellt, ganz vergessen euch zu erzählen.
Ich hab mir doch jetzt so ein bisschen Proxmox basteln
Und vielleicht als Ablösung
Für meinen HP Microserver so nass bestellt
Hier
Beste
Ich hab auch schon mal das interne
OS gesichert
Und Proxmox drauf geknallt
Ging easy, das war es aber auch schon
Mehr hab ich damit noch nicht ausprobiert
Das werden wir uns demnächst im Stream auch angucken
Ob das taugt
Stromverbrauch mal messen und sowas
Wobei ich hab Stromverbrauch schon mal ganz kurz
Gemessen, ich hab so einen Zwischenstecker
Wo man das sehen kann
Das Ding ist echt gut
So einen
ELV
Energy Master
So ein Teil hier
Gratis gibt es das sogar mittlerweile
Da hab ich drei Stück von, die sind echt praktisch
Einfach gucken was Sache ist
und das verbraucht ungefähr 20 watt idle wenn man aber also 20 watt idle mit zwei mit drei mit drei
ssds drin aber wenn man bios tweaks macht kriegt man es auf deutlich unter 20 watt ich habe ein
bisschen rum gebastelt schon ja auf deutlich unter 20 watt wenn man sogar die
wenn man nur 2,5 gig benutzt anstatt 10 gig anstatt das 10 gig interface kriegt
man sogar auf 12 13 watt runter und man kann sicherlich noch mehr ausschalten
aber ganz ehrlich mit um die 20 watt idle ist das schon okay oder besser
gesagt, es sind ja eher so
17, 17, 17
Watt idle mit
10 Gig Interface dran.
Mit ein paar
BIOS Tweaks, die ich auf Reddit gefunden habe.
Da basteln wir demnächst mal ein bisschen dran rum.
Mal gucken,
wie viel
Nass-Performance man da rauskriegt.
Watt
idle mit HDD-Spin-Down.
Würde ich sagen, also es ist mit
ohne Festplatten, ich hab's
nur mal, also ich hab's nur mit einer Festplatte
drin ausprobiert, ja. Also es ist
ohne Festplatten drin mit drei SSDs
drin, also es ist ja da quasi eine interne
SSD und zwei NVMe-SSDs,
die ich
drin hab.
Da ist es eine Ecke unter 20 Watt,
eitel, so 17
oder so würde ich sagen.
16, 17.
Und dann
hab ich mal eine
alte Festplatte reingesteckt.
Und wenn du die spinndownst mit HD-PAM, ist es so 18 Watt, so 18, 19, das schwankt immer ein bisschen.
Also ich denke mal, wenn du da zwei Festplatten reinmachst oder wenn du vier Festplatten reinmachst, je nachdem,
und das spinndownst und vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr im BIOS optimierst,
kommst du so ungefähr mit Spindown wahrscheinlich so um zwischen 20, 22 Watt oder sowas eitel.
Das finde ich ist in Ordnung.
Aber wohlgemerkt, unter Last und mit Platten, die laufen, ist natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr.
Wobei realistisch betrachtet werden ja die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich keine hier,
keine vier Magnetplatten, äh, ja, also klassische Festplatten reinmachen,
sondern wahrscheinlich hier zwei große HDDs und auch mal zwei SSDs oder irgendwie sowas.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Wahrscheinlich eher so die Bestückung.
Ja, aber wo ich mal gespannt drauf bin, ist die Performance.
Weil ich werde das Ding natürlich gleich mal komplett stressen, was NAS angeht.
Da kommt ZFS drauf.
Also ich mache das einfach mit den SSDs, die da eingebaut sind, mit den NVMe SSDs.
Da weiß man auf jeden Fall, die SSD limitiert nicht.
ZFS drauf, mit ZFS Encryption
mit LZ4
Komprimierung, allein schon
das zieht ein bisschen CPU
zieht wahrscheinlich sogar ganz ordentlich CPU
ähm
dann
pack ich mir
Open Media Vault in eine VM
und lasse den quasi
reichen wir das Verzeichnis durch,
also das, was unter der Haube ZFS mit
LZ4-Komprimierung, ZFS-Encryption
ist, verzeichne es durch,
darauf richte ich mir einen Samba-Share ein, dann mal gucken, wie schnell
das noch ist. Mal gucken, ob ich da noch
10 Gig durchkriege.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Schauen wir mal.
Weil ich meine, das Ding, man darf ihn nicht vergessen,
die CPU ist nicht übel,
aber es ist jetzt auch kein Ryzen
oder so also das ding hat fünf kerne vier efficiency course ein performance
kommt hyper threading also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie krasses ding was der
hardware mäßig drin ist
media volt für meine ganze linux us natürlich und platten setup da bin ich
nicht ganz sicher es vermutlich vermutlich werden es 22 hard disks oder oder drei hard
disks werden ich bin mir da noch nicht ganz sicher aber wahrscheinlich werden es zwei
hard disks ein mirror gemeldet wird nur das ist nur dass nur die internen ssds eine hard disk und
dann eine hat es noch wo nächtlich mal erzeugt wird drauf ich halte simpel ja
eventuell auch drei dann mache ich mir über die harte ist noch eine für backups
fünf kerne komische anzahlen warum eigentlich ist das eine ziemlich gute
idee von intel gewesen wie efficiency course ein performance
core das heißt du hast recht nice single single core performance und stromsparende kerne eigentlich
ist für das system ist das ziemlich gute cpu mir persönlich wäre es natürlich lieber da werden
fette reisen drin was noch was noch zur auswahl stand war dieses ding hier bei mir minis forum
Das hat sich ja auch letztens einer im Chat gekauft.
Das hat deutlich, also deutlich, deutlich mehr CPU-Power.
Das verbraucht aber auch eitel um einiges mehr.
N5 Luft.
Die meinen wahrscheinlich leer.
Oder?
Einfach nur das Case.
Was ist denn N5 Luft?
Ja, das ist einfach nur das leere Case.
Ja, ja, das ist nur das leere Case.
Also das hier, die Dinge haben halt deutlich mehr Power.
Das ist schlecht übersetzt.
Das ist China-Chinesen-Kram.
Keine Wunder, dass das so übersetzt ist.
Ja, das hat deutlich mehr Power hier mit einem fetten Ryzen.
Sogar eine ordentliche Ryzen-GPU.
aber das verbraucht ein eitel auch mehr und das ist das ding wo ich bin ich sicher bin braucht
man das ja das wirklich das notwendig für das das 24 7 und es ist deutlich teurer auch
ja also das kostet das kostet dreifache vierfache von dem anderen lass und ist dreifache und braucht
verbraucht Eidl mehr und hat wohl Probleme mit dem SATA-Controller,
habe ich letztens gelesen.
Also, naja, das stand auch noch zur Auswahl.
Aber ich habe mich jetzt erstmal für das entschieden.
Wenn es nichts taucht, kann ich es immer noch zurückschicken, Amazon Beste.
Aber wir probieren das mal aus.
Wie weit du die Watt gedrückt bekommst, ja, müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Also so viel kannst du da nicht machen.
Das BIOS ist in der Standardversion super krass minimalistisch,
aber es gibt einen Trick, wie man ins Advanced-BIOS kommt,
wo man viel mehr einstellen kann.
Warst du das der Letztens
erzählt hat? Er hat sich gerade noch, bevor die Rampreise
so teuer geworden sind, so nass gekauft
mit 128 Gig.
Irgendjemand im Chat hat das Letztes
geschrieben.
Weil China Chinesen Seite.
So, ich wollte gerade noch mal gucken, was in Goat rendet, haben wir nicht.
Netmaker, was ist das denn?
Ey, mein interessantes Projekt zur Abwechslung.
Netmaker.
Netmaker makes networks.
Ach, wie, wirklich?
Und der Fiat Champ champ Fiat.
Lass mich gerade mal gucken, wie viele Userfehler es wieder gibt.
Okay, Userfehler.
Netmakers.
Was macht das jetzt genau?
Wireguard Automation from Homelab to Enterprise.
Aha.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es sein soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, ich check's nicht, aber sicherlich
HiaQ Software.
Ja, und übrigens hier als
SSDs
Als SSDs habe ich
2,99 pro
SSDs drin. Allerdings
eine 1TB und eine 2TB.
Warum? Weil ich die noch da
hab.
Ja, ist vielleicht nicht das Schlauste,
eine 2 TB und eine 1 TB SSD zu mirrorn.
Das heißt, man hat dann quasi aus einer 2 TB SSD
eine 1 TB SSD gemacht.
Aber allemal besser, als nochmal...
Wie viel kostet's?
Ähm...
Allemal besser, als nochmal 336 Euro ausgeben,
einfach so, weil's geht.
Ne?
chat geben so sieht's aus
doch dann lassen wir lassen wir mal eine sache gucken was trendet denn in der
rastwelt blazing fast ritten in rast was flow surface crypto 8 mal wieder crypto
stellt in letzter zeit trennt nur ai ai ai ai mal zur abwechslung wieder
Blockchain-Krypto-Kram.
Das ist ja schon so
2023,
22, dass das trendet.
Hattest du mal deine
lokalen LLM in Home Assistant drin?
Nee, hatte ich noch nie.
Wie viel kostet so eine SSD mittlerweile?
Wie gesagt, 240 Euro.
Mit 2 TB NVMe.
Und das geht noch teurer.
Wenn du wirklich eine ganz schnelle
neue willst, du brauchst aber auch
das passende Mainboard für,
dann brauchst
So, Bitcoin ist gestern wirklich?
Das heißt, ich soll jetzt reingehen, oder was?
Krass.
Boah, von 100k
runter auf 66.000.
Heftig.
Okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt Bitcoin kaufen, ja.
Kaufe ich mir doch mal einen Bitcoin.
Ne, kaufe ich mir nicht.
So, wenn du eine ganz furchtbar schnelle SSD willst, dann musst du dir so eine kaufen.
Da brauchst du aber auch ein Mainboard mit PCI Express 5.0.
Die ist dann noch ein bisschen teurer.
So, so viel kosten aktuelle SSDs.
Das ist also ganz schön teuer geworden.
So
Dann gucken wir mal, was es auf YouTube so gibt, oder?
Ach ne, ich wollte ja gucken, was bei Rust so trendet
Goose
Das habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, ganz ehrlich
Ich habe da mehr erwartet von
Das lag aber auch daran, dass meine lokalen LLM-Signale nicht damit klar gekommen sind
Daraufhin habe ich dann Open Code ausprobiert, was mir deutlich besser gefallen hat.
So, dann gibt es...
...Kitz...
...Kra...
...Was auch immer.
Multi-Functional App to find duplicates, empty folders, similar images.
Okay, was auch immer.
Das kann zumindest schon mal kein Mensch aussprechen.
Ah, das ist polnisch.
Verstehe.
Ja, wie? Heißt es jetzt
Krokiet oder
oder
Krawka?
Memory safe. Übrigens, Leute,
jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Angenommen, ihr würdet ein Projekt auf GitHub
veröffentlichen.
Würdet ihr dann unter Features aufnehmen,
not wipecoded,
Wenn es Not Vibe Coded ist.
Ich glaube, im Jahr 2026 ist das eher ein Qualitätsmerkmal.
Also, wenn ich was veröffentlichen würde, jetzt, würde ich reinschreiben Not Vibe Coded.
Aha, damit kann man ähnliche Bilder finden.
Warum fackelt hier irgendwas auf seine Hochzeit ab?
Achso, das sind MP3s.
Codex, AI.
Codex ist der OpenAI Cloud Code Verschnitt.
Git AI.
Moment, Moment.
Git-Extension for Tracking AI-Generated Code in your Repos.
What?
Warum braucht man denn sowas?
Mr. R.S.
AI.
Burn.
Commodore.
Ähm.
Docker-Management-Stells.
Sah eigentlich ganz nice aus.
Ich hab mir die ganzen Sachen ja mal angeguckt.
Coolify, Docploy, Commodore und was nicht.
Gibt ja noch mehr Sachen.
Ähm.
An sich fand ich...
Also da gibt es eine Demo von.
Fand ich das ganz cool, aber ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Irgendwas hat mir gefehlt dabei.
Hat mir nicht so gefallen.
Also ich finde immer noch Docploi so für...
Lokales...
Lokales Cloud-Style-Interface am besten.
Coolify habe ich nicht richtig ausprobiert.
Da habe ich mir auch nur die Demo angeguckt.
Andorra Launcher.
Minecraft-Launcher.
Just Command Runner.
Wie viele von diesen Dinger brauchen wir denn eigentlich noch?
Da gibt es auch 100.000 von.
Ich muss mich jetzt mal outen, Chat.
Ich muss mich jetzt mal outen.
Warum braucht man ein Makefile oder einen Command Runner,
wenn man auch einfach Shell-Skripts in das Repo legen kann?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich dazu zu kacknub für.
Aber ich meine, guck mal.
Ich kann doch hier ein Build und ein Run-SH in das Repo legen.
Warum sollte ich mir ein Just-File oder ein Make-File reinlegen und darin dann meine Sachen definieren?
Einheitliche Ausführsprache.
Ja, aber ich kann auch in jedes meiner Repos, wenn ich das will, die Skripts legen.
Dann führe ich immer Run aus, was ist unter der Haube.
Letztendlich benutzen die ja auch nur Shell-Skripts.
Warum ist das besser?
Das habe ich noch nie gecheckt.
Es muss ja irgendwas dran sein, dass das so verbreitet ist.
Diese Dinger.
Aber ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Kennst du Kagi?
Nee.
Okay, okay.
Wir fragen, wir fragen.
Wir fragen mal heute.
Komm, fang mal Google.
Wir können auch Perplexity fragen.
Okay, also.
Was ist der Vorteil von Makefiles, Justfiles, etc. vs. einfach ein run.sh, build.sh checken.
So, Perplexity.
Der Kernvorteil von Makefiles gegenüber nackten run.sh, build.sh.
Alter, Perplexity, ich schwätze da auch wieder.
Dass sie explizit Aufgabenabhängigkeit...
Okay, das stimmt.
Wenn man Dependencies modellieren will, wenn man sagen...
Sagen wir mal, du hast fünf Jobs und sagst hier Job A muss vorher Job B und C laufen haben.
Okay, dafür lasse ich es mir gefallen, aber das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Warum du hier bist?
Ja, vielleicht lernst du ja noch was.
High IQ Chat.
Wobei, eigentlich ist der...
Also der Chat ist durch die ganzen Subscriptions heute eigentlich schon eher so.
Der Kopf, der wird immer größer.
Yeah.
alles heil hat sich einer aller tasklisten abhängigkeiten definieren cross plattform
benutzt das auf der arbeit gefühlt 100 1000 1000 c make aksa aha ok
am schelz kripp ist auch kurz plattform weil letztendlich die sachen die du in
deine make file aus fürste ist ist ja auch nur shell oder also ich habe mal
einen guide zu make files gesehen da haben die im endeffekt bash in make
files geschrieben nur dass man das eklig formatieren musste dass es funktioniert
warum warum macht kummer wenn ihr wenn ihr euer projekt bilden wollen warum
warum keine bild punkt sh das ist auch cross-plattform zumindest da überall
wo ne Bash läuft.
Na gut, das ist nicht wirklich Cross-Plattform.
Das stimmt schon.
So, also was sagt er?
Explizite Target statt
einzelner Skripte.
Du hast einen einheitlichen Einstiegspunkt.
Okay,
ich verstehe es.
Okay, das leuchtet mir ein, wenn man mehr als Run-SH und Build-SH haben will, ja, wenn man jetzt 20 verschiedene Tasks hat, dann ist natürlich ein bisschen viel, ja, dann ist natürlich ein bisschen viel jetzt in seinem Projekt Repo, Root, Build-Run, Tests, Plup-SH, Keckel-SH, Omega-Lull.SH liegen zu haben, aber dann könnte man einfach einen Ordner machen, Skripts.
abhängigkeit und inkrementelle bild das handelt bei mir ähnlich make sondern das
handelt bei mir das jeweilige bild tool der sprache aus dass es c&c plus plus
teilweise wieder aufnahme beim nächsten lauf dort weitermachen ja
Syntax für OS-spezifische Befehle
schon sehr angenehm. Okay.
Leuchtet mir ein. Ja.
Parallelisierung.
Okay, das stimmt.
Wobei ich halt, ich halt, guck mal.
Wenn ich mir so ein Bildpunkt-SH baue,
das hält sich ja immer sehr in Grenzen.
Ich rufe ja da drin die jeweilige
Sache
Tools auf von der jeweiligen
Sprache, die ich ver... das ist jetzt
in viel kürzerer Zeit geht's nicht mehr, ja.
Ähm, ich würde dann hier
dann auch CMake aufrufen oder so für C.
Wenn verschiedene Teams an verschiedenen Teilen eines großen Projekts
arbeiten, dann könnte man bauen, Linken mit Makefiles
in den einzelnen Teilen einfacher managen als mit
Jellyskripten.
Das kann sein.
Wenn wir bauen und linken...
Das liegt aber eigentlich nur daran, dass das Bilden von C und C++ Anwendung kacke ist, oder?
Also über C will ich jetzt nicht so schimpfen.
C ist schön konsistent und minimalistisch.
Und C++...
Davon fange ich jetzt nicht an, Leute.
Ich wollte gerade schon wieder einsteigen.
Aber nee, nee, nee.
Davon fange ich heute nicht an.
Ihr wisst, was passiert, wenn ich wieder anfange von C++, Alter.
Das dauert jetzt eine halbe Stunde und ich rage wiederum.
Standardisierte Bedienung im Team.
Okay.
Bessere Strukturierung von Aufgaben.
Wenn simples Run-SH reicht, kleines Projektbild dauert Sekunden, keine komplexen Abhängigkeiten.
Okay.
Viele wiederkehrende Tasks.
Größere Codebasis.
mehrere Entwickler, die sich nicht durch
Skripte und Doku kämpfen sollen.
Ah.
CICD, wo diesen Targets
konsistent auf... Das verstehe ich auch. Das kann auch
Bildpunkt.sh aufrufen.
Hast du mittlerweile
die C++ Bashing...
Stimmt, das haben wir nie fertig geguckt.
Wir sind bis zur Hälfte
gekommen. Jetzt habe ich das wieder vergessen.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das müssen wir irgendwann
fertig gucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo wir aufgehört haben
Hier irgendwo, hä?
Ah, das gucken wir jetzt nicht fertig
Aber das müssen wir noch fertig gucken, ja, ja
Wir haben nur die Hälfte oder so geguckt
Das Video ist echt gut
Passt gut zusammen
Was, und nicht mal alles, was an C++ schlecht ist
Also, Spoiler, so gut wie alles.
Okay.
Ah ja, gut.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Was trendet noch bei Rust?
Just lucked.
Linux GPU Configuration Monitoring Tool.
Aha. Lucked.
Now. Boah, da ist er hier.
Guck mal hier.
Der ist ja top aktuell hier.
Der hat eben gerade gepusht.
Was? Lass das MILF-Video schauen.
Nee, das schauen wir nicht.
Linux, give me my drawing tool.
Aha.
Das gucken wir, das Video.
Was du gerade gepostet hast.
Das habe ich ja schon auf.
Windows 11 zwingt mich dazu.
Ich könnte werten, er hat das bisher so gemacht wie ich.
Dass er Linux und Windows
beide benutzt hat.
Weil jemand, der hier IT-mäßig im Security-Bereich
unterwegs ist. Windows-Owned, die kann ich mir eigentlich
gar nicht vorstellen.
Er ist ja durch bei.
Open Source Search,
AI,
UV. Wisst ihr, was ich
mal ausprobieren wollte?
OX
für Python. Kennt das jemand?
OX? Das da?
Da habe ich
nämlich gelesen, in den Docs
von OX
ähm
äh
Wo ist es denn?
So ein Bundle gab es da doch.
Bin ich jetzt blöd?
Wo ist es denn?
Ne, das hieß nicht Ox.
Das hieß...
Oxidize oder so?
Kann das sein?
nee alle wie ist das denn dass das könnte sein
da habe ich letztendlich kann man peisen anwendungen wohl bandeln so dass sie auf
allen linux system laufen ohne ohne externe dependencies das wollte ich mal
ausprobieren
sowas geht schon lange lol geht das schon lange wirklich und wie
also alles was ich nur gefunden habe für peisen hat irgendwelche abhängigkeiten die das sehr
eklig in der benutzung machen und das hier soll nun wirklich ein echtes elf contain binary
raushauen geht das nicht mit installer nicht bei installer hast du lieb c und
hast du geduld an abhängigkeiten
aber für kommandozeilen tools löst kein docker image ja alles in eine eckse
packen das ist kein ding das geht aber du willst ja dass das binary ausführbar
ist. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wenn du was mit Pi-Installer packst,
dann hat das zumindest eine Abhängigkeit
auf die GLIPC-Version
von einem System, wo du das gebaut hast.
Mindestens das.
Das habe ich schon ausprobiert. Ne, ne.
Aber anscheinend
ist das Projekt dead, kann das sein?
Ist es dead?
Es scheint dead zu sein.
Project Status Update.
Okay.
Oh, anscheinend ist das der Adge.
Naja.
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
Was ist denn Cson schon wieder?
Was ist das?
Super Set of Programming.
Ja und wie sieht es da mit static binary aus?
Compilers, das geht bestimmt auch nicht richtig.
zu lenke folie static executable wenn den linken klutz das ist ja schon wieder ekliger
Mal gucken.
Is it possible to read?
Naja, egal.
So.
Ist
das nicht dieses Projekt,
wo jeder
was posten kann
und dann wird gevotet, was gemerged wird?
Habe ich letztens, glaube ich, bei Hacker News
letztens irgendeinen Post drüber gelesen.
Wurde heute schon über Moldbot gesprochen?
Du meinst OpenClaude oder was?
Oder meinst du wirklich MoldBook?
So, dann gucken wir doch jetzt das Video hier.
Hat der Chat jetzt schon ein paar Mal vorgeschlagen.
Windows, das ist auch ein top aktuelles Video von Morpheus.
Windows 11 zwingt mich dazu.
Er schreit auf Linux um.
Wie gesagt, ich gehe ganz stark davon aus,
der hat die ganze Zeit auch schon Linux verwendet.
Ich mache es ja auch schon seit Jahren so.
Ich habe hier meinen Linux und hier meinen Windows.
und ich benutze Linux für alles, wo sich Linux gut eignet
und ich benutze Windows für alles, wo sich Windows gut eignet.
Windows eignet sich eigentlich im Prinzip bei mir nur für Spielesachen gut.
Und für den Fall der Fälle, wenn ich Videos mache,
dann halt fürs, oder hier, fürs Streamen
und für Video-Thumbnails erstellen und sowas.
Wobei ich das sicherlich auch unter, also gerade Videos,
da wollte ich mir schon lange mal DaVinci Resolve angucken,
was ja auch native unter Linux läuft.
OBS müsste eigentlich unter Linux, das was ich hier mache, müsste wahrscheinlich unter OBS, unter Linux auch ganz gut funktionieren.
Ich meine, im Prinzip capture ich einfach nur den Screen.
Wobei man da sich wieder fragt, wenn ich Wayland verwende, Leute, wie sieht es mit OBS und Wayland aus?
Kann man da den Screen capturen mittlerweile?
Das ist ja unter Wayland einfache Sache, nicht unbedingt immer selbstverständlich.
Ja, VMware ist auf 60 FPS gecappt, das stimmt.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt sagen muss, im Terminal sind mir 60 FPS genug.
Das reicht.
Warum brauchst du mehr als 60 FPS im Terminal?
Aber es wäre natürlich schon nice, könnte ich da mehr benutzen.
Was Moldbook ist, was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Moldbook.
KI-Agenten drehen frei auf Reddit-Klon.
Wie Reddit, aber nur für Bots.
Die Plattform Moldbook für Diskussionen zwischen KI-Agenten entwickelt sich...
Ach du Scheiße.
AI-Slob versus AI-Slob, oder was?
Okay, ich weiß auf jeden Fall, dass ich das definitiv nicht im Stream öffnen werde.
Wer weiß, was man da sieht.
Wenn Bots mit Bots reden.
Erinnert sich noch einer
an eines der ersten
AI-Experimente von Microsoft?
Damals, als X noch Twitter war,
hatten die einen Bot,
der
möglichst, ja,
wie sagt man das so,
so menschennah reden sollte,
ja, also so menschenähnlich
reden sollte.
Und der Bot hat halt gelernt, was Leute so schreiben und wie die sich verhalten und so.
Und hat dann auf einmal angefangen, irgendwelche Nazi-Sprüche zu machen.
Dann haben sie den Bot wieder abgeschaltet.
Tai, irgendwie so. Ja, ja, ja, genau. So hieß das Ding.
So hieß das Ding.
Okay, dann gucken wir jetzt von Morpheus das Video.
Lass mal hier kurz die Musik aus.
Düdüdüdü.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
So.
Windows 11 zwingt mich dazu.
Ich bin weg von Windows und mache jetzt alles unter Linux.
Mit einem Setup, bei dem man eigentlich denken würde, dass das alles unmöglich sein sollte.
Es war aber nicht nur einfacher als jemals zuvor, meines Erachtens...
Gut, das, ich versuche das jetzt mal nicht alle zwei Sekunden zu überbrechen, das stimmt, das sehe ich genauso.
Es war noch nie so einfach wie jetzt, Linux zu verwenden.
Das heißt nicht, dass alles geht. Es war noch nie so einfach wie jetzt.
Ich glaube, man kann tatsächlich mit ruhigem Gewissen sagen, wir waren noch nie so nah dran am Jahr des Linux-Desktops wie 2026.
Ich glaube nicht, dass 2026 wirklich das Jahr des Linux-Desktops wird. Ich glaube übrigens, dass es nie das Jahr des Linux-Desktops geben wird, sondern dass es eine schleichende Entwicklung sein wird. Aber wir waren noch nie so nah dran und der Hype ist auf jeden Fall in letzter Zeit deutlich spürbar.
Das liegt an mehreren Sachen.
Das liegt einmal daran, dass Microsoft mittlerweile Microslop ist und Windows so beschissen wie nie zuvor.
Und dass viele auf YouTube, auch richtig große Leute wie PewDiePie und sowas, auf Linux-Dials aufgesprungen sind.
Beides Sachen, die nicht schlecht sind für Linux.
Es ist auch so dringend wie nie zuvor, dass wir uns digital unabhängig machen.
Im großen Stil.
Ich bin vor einigen Jahren für die Arbeit von Linux zurück zu Windows gewechselt.
Wegen meines Setups.
Hier, fünf Bildschirme.
Einer davon ist sogar nur über USB.
Alter.
Über drei bald.
Ich komme mit zwei Bildschirmen hier schon zu voll vor auf dem Schreibtisch.
Was brauchst du denn für einen massive Schreibtisch?
Einer für fünf Bildschirme.
USB angeschlossen.
Eine Kamera, die nur HDMI als Ausgang hat.
Mit einem Prompte am Start noch.
Ja gut.
Sogar nur über USB angeschlossen.
Gut, für ihn ist es natürlich sehr sinnvoll, ja, mit so einem Promptor, weil er steht halt vor der Kamera und sagt was dazu.
Ich kann ohne Probleme in ein Skript gucken und vorlesen, weil mich sieht ja keiner dabei.
Das ist eine Kamera, die nur HDMI als Ausgang hat.
Moment, Moment, Moment, ich muss noch kurz was, kurz was checken.
Was hat er da hinten am Start?
Das ist eine Kamera, die nur HDMI als Ausgang hat.
deshalb eine Capture Card braucht. Ein Stream Deck für das Elgato keinen offiziellen Support bietet.
Ich schneide Videos mit professioneller Software. Ich brauche Bildbearbeitungssoftware, mache
Buchhaltung, entwickle Software auf alle möglichen Arten und bin sogar Leidenschaftsführer.
Buchhaltung ist ein guter... Ich hab von meinem Steuerberater gar nichts mehr gehört seit Dezember.
Müsste jetzt ja langsam mal fertig sein. ...fremdlicher Gamer. Das sind alles Themen,
für die man zumindest teilweise vor einigen Jahren noch Windows brauchte. Doch die Zeiten haben sich
geändert. Während Windows immer schlechter und problematischer wurde, war es noch nie einfacher
und komfortabler Linux zu nutzen als heute. Und selbst bei diesem Setup und all diesen
Tätigkeiten ist Linux heutzutage Windows überlegen. Oder vielleicht gerade deswegen.
Das hier ist meine ganz persönliche Geschichte, warum aber auch wie genau ich Windows den Rücken
und ehrlich gesagt mich das erste mal endlich wieder wohl fühle wenn ich den rechner an machen
und ich hoffe dass dieses video auch dich motivieren kann umzusteigen denn dieses video
ist teil der digital independence days die der chaos computer club beim 39 c3 sich alles gibt
und darf demnach sehr sehr gerne geteilt verliehen hast du dein steuerberater dazu
überredet linux zu benutzen ich glaube das werden wir auch nicht mehr erleben auch eingebettet
werden und kleines foreshadowing natürlich habe ich mal wieder übertrieben ich nutze ein system
das sich selbst repariert wenn ich es kaputt machen für den editor das gibt sieht man selten
und das ist schon mehr als einmal vorgekommen aber dazu später mehr zunächst mal warum der
umstieg windows hat sich mit windows 10 und windows 11 einige wirklich unschöne dinge
geleistet wenn ihr das new outlook e mail programm nutzt synchronisiert microsoft eure
E-Mail-Passwörter
mache ich nicht, habe ich auch nicht vor.
Microsoft kann mich mal.
Mit ihrer Cloud, auch ohne, dass sie zustimmt übrigens.
Microsofts Recall AI
macht außerdem alle paar Sekunden
einen Screenshot von eurem Desktop,
damit ihr mit KI eure Tätigkeiten
durchsuchen könnt. Völlig egal, ob ihr
gerade intime Videos schaut mit eurer
Therapeutin. Und, und, und
mittlerweile hat jedes
Kack-Windows-Tool irgendeinen
Co-Pilot-Button. Ich meine, seriously.
Notepad, der
Der most basic, billig Schrott Texteditor aller Zeiten hat ein Copilot-Button, ey.
Sign-in, nee.
Paint hat ein Copilot.
Die Pappen mit, ich glaube, das Vibe-Coden, die.
Ohne Scheiß, ich glaube wirklich, Microsoft Vibe-Coded das.
Selber.
Hat nicht sogar der Microsoft-Chef letztens selbst erzählt, dass 30% des Codes bei Microsoft mittlerweile von AI erstellt wird?
Und hat er nicht auch letztens eine Rundmail an seine Mitarbeiter geschrieben?
Wer keinen Bock auf AI hat, soll sich verpissen, so sinngemäß.
Ach ja, und zur Windows-Uhr gibt es nur zu sagen, ich hoffe, ich hoffe das ist jetzt auch so.
Ah ne, okay. Weil manchmal, wenn man die Uhr-App öffnet, die Uhr-App kommt erstmal, Moment, es muss ein Update für die Uhr-App installiert werden. Ein Update für die Uhr, Alter. Weiter.
Oder wie die Speicher auf dem Rechner habt, der von den Bildern dann belegt wird.
Mit Windows 11 seid ihr außerdem gezwungen, ein TPM, ein Trusted Platform Module in eurer Hardware zu haben.
Allein dieser Fakt, dass alle anderen rausgeworfen werden, befördert geschätzte 240 Millionen Computer und Laptop auf den Müllhaufen.
Lass mich das nochmal sagen. 240 Millionen...
Chat, das habe ich auch gelesen. Angeblich machen die jetzt Qualitätsoffensive, das habe ich auch gelesen.
Ganz ehrlich, sollen sie erstmal zeigen, dass sie das machen.
Labern ist billig, ja? Machen ist dann wieder was anderes.
Beim Taschenrechner auf meinem Arbeitslaptop kommt inzwischen ein Splash-Screen beim Starten.
Ja.
Soweit sind wir schon, ne?
Soll ich mal im Calculator gucken?
Ah, der muss sich nicht updaten.
Das ist halt echt lächerlich, ne?
Wie gesagt, es gab jetzt einen Bug, dass Windows nicht mehr runterfährt.
Also man kann den Computer nicht mehr richtig ausschalten.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Geräte Schrott.
Geplante Obsoleszenz in einem Ausmaß,
das man sich nicht mal mehr vorstellen kann.
Und das in Zeiten, wo Hardware so teuer ist,
dass ich ein Video darüber gemacht habe.
Sie speichern außerdem die Schlüssel
eurer Festplattenverschlüsselung.
Wie gesagt, BitLocker ist bei mir
von Anfang an unten durch gewesen.
Seit BitLocker neu war und dann die News kam,
du kannst dein Passwort
oder du kannst deine
BitLocker Sachen restauren,
wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast.
Moment, das kann halt sein
ordentliche Verschlüsselung heißt, Passwort weg, ich hab gelitten
ja, sobald es
restorebar ist, hat Microsoft da irgendwas
das darf nicht sein, seitdem hab ich
nicht mal ernsthaft dran gedacht, ich verwende
VeraCrypt
unter Windows immer noch, das funktioniert auch ganz gut
mittlerweile auch
mit SecureBoot
das ist halt echt der Witz
...online
und geben sie an Strafverfolgungsbehörden
raus und Windows
sendet natürlich jede Menge an
Telemetriedaten, um euch
passende Werbung im Startmenü zu
zeigen oder auch einfach zu installieren.
Deswegen hatten wir alle zu einer
gewissen Zeit Candy Crush
vorinstalliert. Achso, und natürlich
hält sich Microsoft nicht daran, wenn ihr
sagt, dass ihr eure Daten eigentlich gerne
gar nicht einwählen wollt.
Wenn du Windows 11
installiert hast und klickst
diesen Installer durch,
du kannst ja bei vielen Sachen gar nicht mehr
auswählen, nein, will ich nicht.
Du kannst nur noch sagen, only basic.
Geh in die Mühe.
Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, will ich nicht.
Will Microsoft nicht, dass du das sagst, will ich nicht.
Ehrengast bei den Big Brother Awards ist.
Dazu kamen nicht bessere, sondern schlechtere Erfahrungen.
Es gibt einen Bug, dass Windows nicht mehr richtig runterfährt.
Sondern immer und immer wieder.
Windows 11 kam mit einem miesen Fehler bei Ryzen-Prozessoren.
den haben wir Benutzer oftmals gar nicht so richtig mitbekommen.
Der hat aber heimlich bis zu 15% eurer Leistung on top gefressen
und wurde erst mehrere Monate später repariert.
Manche Settings haben sich hinter zig verschiedenen Menüs versteckt,
weil sie von...
Please, nicht die Systemsteuerung weg.
Oh, ihr Leute.
Also, wir hatten es doch letzten schon mal.
Guckt mal.
Ich gehe in Settings und jetzt will ich einfach nur gucken, was ich für eine IP-Adresse habe auf meiner Netzwerkkarte.
Was meine Rechnerkarte für eine IP-Adresse hat.
Und was zeigt der mir an?
ETH2 not connected.
Warum?
Das ist mir doch scheißegal, das nicht connected.
Warum zeigst du nicht mir meine Netzwerkkarte an, die connected ist?
So, ich habe lange gebraucht
Und nur mit Hilfe des Chats
Habe ich das rausgefunden, wie das funktioniert
Es gibt hier irgendwo ein Advanced-Button
Ne, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen
Chat, ich habe es vergessen
Wo muss ich hin, dass ich meine Netzwerksachen sehe
Network
Chat, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen
Wie kann ich meine IP-Adresse
Also ich weiß, wie man es sehen kann
Aber ich meine mit in der neuen Systemsteuerung
Ähm, wo ist denn der Knopf
Es gab doch irgendwo einen Advance-Knopf, wie man da hinkommt, oder?
Chat, das haben wir doch letztens...
Wo ist der Advance-Knopf hin? Ist der weg?
Mach das Fenster mal groß, meinst du, dann steht mehr da?
Der ist weg.
War der nicht letztens noch...
Jetzt mal ohne Scheiß, vor zwei Wochen im Stream war doch hier noch ein Advance-Knopf.
Guck mal, ich will mir einfach nur die IP-Adressen von meiner Netzwerkkarte anzeigen lassen.
Das geht nicht.
Artstealings habe ich doch hier schon
Geh mal eins zurück auf
Network und Internet, bin ich doch hier
So, aber hier, Advanced, okay, okay
Okay, logisch, logisch, Advanced
Ähm, hier
So, und das ist auch geil
Hier steht nicht etwa die IP-Adresse
Oder sowas drinnen
Da steht drinnen, ähm
Hier, Bytes received
Die IP-Adresse steht da nicht
So, Additional Properties
Da steht die, also sowas dämliches
alter sowas dummes ja ich weiß dass ich leute ich weiß wie man sich anzeigen lässt aber wie geht es
um die neue systemstelle der fuck ja hier control panel network network sharing dass hier wenn du
hier bei den adapter settings bist also da wurde eigentlich früher schneller hingekommen ist wenn
er einfach unten hingeklickt bist hast du hier das ding klickst drauf da siehst du okay sagt
bumm sieht man auch nicht die ip details da stets also richtig hängen geblieben
und noch was hier diese settings hier für die maus
da gibt es viele sachen auch nicht über settings menü
Es geht mir gar nicht so sehr darum, wie die Anzahl der Klicks, es geht mir eher darum, wie logisch oder unlogisch es ist, was zu finden.
Windows 7 oder gar noch früher mitkam, aber Teile waren eben schon umgezogen in ein moderneres Menü.
Manches konnte man gar nicht mehr reparieren, ohne das Terminal oder die PowerShell zu benutzen.
Die Bing-Suche hat sich in das Startmenü beschlichen und es häufig quasi unbrauchbar gemacht.
Und ich habe bis zum Ende es nicht hinbekommen...
Übrigens, übrigens, übrigens, ähm...
Ich habe jetzt nicht geprüft, ob das stimmt, aber ich habe das letztens auf Reddit gelesen.
Ja, ich wollte es auch erst gar nicht glauben.
Das Startmenü von Windows 11 ist angeblich eine React-Anwendung.
Stimmt das?
Das ist angeblich eine React-Anwendung.
Kein Witz, hab ich gelesen
Also das ist kein UWP oder
Irgend so ein Microsoft eigener Shit, das ist eine React Anwendung
Also ich weiß nicht, was mit denen los ist
Pixel Buds erfolgreich mit Windows zu verbinden
Und das sind nur ein paar wenige
Der vielen Probleme
Klar, jetzt kann man sagen, man kann das alles
Beheben und einstellen
aber eine cpu spiked wenn du die windows taste spams okay wollen wir mal
ausprobieren windows manager
wo sieht man das jetzt hier am schönsten
naja da muss man schon schneller späme
also ich kann nicht viel schneller sparen meine cpu spiked nicht wir können
mal hier gucken ob da irgendwas spiked
Ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, aber...
Was die GPU spiked...
Naja, würde ich jetzt nicht so sagen.
Wäre ja auch hart, wenn eine 4090 spiked beim Startmenü oder die CPU.
Ne, nur eine 4090, keine 5090.
Wenn man das kann, dann braucht man genau diese technischen Kenntnisse, die man Linux ja eigentlich immer vorgefasst hat.
Du guckst die ganze Zeit bei GPU? Was? Quatsch, mach ich überhaupt nicht.
Hier, CPU.
CPU?
Achso.
Aber ich hab da oben hingeguckt.
Aber hier spiked auch nix.
Guck.
Also hält sich sehr in Grenzen.
sich mal eben als Fass aufmachen. Mit Trump haben die USA eine Richtung eingeschlagen,
die ich mal ganz schlicht als schwer berechenbar bezeichnen würde. Unser langjähriger Handelspartner
könnte uns morgen den Sack abgeben. Das bedeutet ein digitaler Handelskrieg für uns,
nicht dass morgen der Bildschirm schwarz wird. Es ist sehr viel subtiler. Es bedeutet,
dass wir die Souveränität über unsere Werkzeuge verlieren. Wenn Microsoft die Preise verdoppelt
oder Daten als Währung nutzt,
sind wir keine Kunden mehr.
Wir sind die Geiseln.
Wir müssen mitmachen, wenn wir keine Alternative haben.
Das heißt eher, wir machen uns ab.
Ey, ey, Leute, Leute, Leute.
Wir haben noch die Magenta Cloud.
Da kann doch gar nichts passieren.
Oder was wir jetzt haben, ist die Lidl Cloud.
Und die Lidl Cloud,
also die heißt nicht wirklich Lidl Cloud,
aber das ist letztendlich Lidl.
Die Lidl Cloud ist wohl,
habe ich gehört, habe ich selbst noch nie verwendet,
wohl gar nicht so kacke, wie man sich das so denkt.
Das geht sogar so weit, dass bei mir auf der Arbeit jetzt
ein Testaufbau in der Lidl-Cloud passieren soll,
ob man das irgendwie benutzen kann.
Was Microsoft, Trump oder einfach die gesamte Weltwirtschaft gerade so tut.
Wenn Trump Zölle auf Europa schlägt, kann es durchaus vorkommen,
dass die EU mit Digitalzöllen ankommt oder antwortet.
Dadurch werden alle digitalen Produkte schlagartig teurer.
Das gilt natürlich auch, wenn Microsoft einfach Bock darauf hat,
so wie beispielsweise mit dem Game Pass.
Doch, doch, doch, du kannst, wobei weiß ich nicht.
Stack it, genau.
Ähm, weiße.
Stack it, Kubernetes.
ist die webseite die webseite war das letzte mal noch so komisch gelb warum sieht die jetzt anders
aus die webseite sieht ganz anders aus als das letzte mal noch produkt über server update
es ist der windows server okay guck mal da jetzt beraten lassen das ganz ehrlich das ding wäre bei
mir schon komplett raus preisliste das wäre komplett raus wenn man nicht hier einfach
sieht das für server gibt es dieses ganze gelaber können die sich eigentlich komplett sparen ich
will sehen diese server gibt es des kost fertig stress interessiert mich nicht preisliste compute
engine man meint ernsthaft ich muss in einem fucking pdf gucken in einem pdf
weil ich verarschen ich wusste den pdf gucken dass ich weiß was der kram kostet
miene vereinbaren meine güte also okay ich habe nichts gesagt sorry
leute ich habe nichts gesagt ich muss nicht in pdf gucken
Okay, okay, okay
Also was haben wir denn hier?
Hardware, AMD, Single
Region Österreich
Das kannst du auch schon mal, also die Webseite ist, naja
Stündlich, monatlich, gucken wir mal
was das kostet
Ordentlich teuer, gucken wir mal
Vergleich zu Hetzner, was es kostet, 4 Kerne
8 GB
Boah, alter
Das sind ja fast schon Google Preise
Das ist aber teuer as fuck
Also für mich jetzt
Wenn es die Firma bezahlt wäre mir das egal
Also
Das dürfte ungefähr das sein
Was eine Compute Engine
Bei GCP auch kostet
Guck mal
mal gcp calculator
compute engine number of instances usage ja das ist also ein 24 7 provisioning
model blablabla in vier standard zwei cpu standard 4
ja guck guck das kostet fast das sage ich doch das ist ähnliche preis dafür gibt es
aber 16 gb
Machen wir mal hier auch nur 8.
Bisschen billiger.
Ja, also das sind tatsächlich ordentlich
kostet das.
Also das ist wirklich...
Also generell muss man sagen,
VMs sind bei Google
und bei Azure, die sind nicht billig.
Gut,
es ist vielleicht ein bisschen unfair, das mit Hetzner
zu vergleichen. Wenn du dir bei Hetzner
einen Server kaufst, dann ist das irgendein
äh
ja,
Consumer Mainboard
mit super
kosteneffizient gemacht.
Das, aber
letztendlich
finde ich das, also für
einzelne VMs, finde ich, lohnt sich das in der Cloud
nicht für Otto-Normalverbraucher
oder Hoster wie mich.
Wenn man das jetzt mal, also das ist
eher was, wenn man eh schon in
dieser Cloud unterwegs ist, dort ein Managed
Kubernetes-Cluster hat, vielleicht Managed-Staatenbanken
bei Google ist es ja mittlerweile so,
GCP, ich bin jetzt nicht eingeloggt,
aber ich weiß nicht, vielleicht sieht man das hier irgendwie,
genau, dieses Menü hier
neben, ja, bei Google,
das ist mittlerweile, ist das,
ähm,
ja, das ist
mittlerweile irgendwie gefühlt 8 Seiten lang,
die haben ja alles mögliche,
von Datenbanken, NoSQL, VMs,
Kubernetes Cluster, PubSub,
alles mögliche, die haben ja wirklich tausend Sachen,
ich glaube so viel haben die bei Lidl noch nicht,
aber wenn man halt eh schon in dem Ökosystem drin ist, dann kauft man sich halt auch seine VMs.
Wenn ich einfach nur eine VM möchte, dann würde ich garantiert weder zu Azure, noch zu AWS, noch zu Google, noch zu Lidl gehen,
sondern dann würde ich zum Beispiel zu Hetzner gehen, Cloud, so, Xdeep, Losting, bla bla bla, Prices.
Meinen Lieblingsserver haben sie leider bei Hetzner auch abgeschafft, mein Lieblingsserver war der mit drei Kernen,
drei Kerne, den gibt es nicht mehr, aber die anderen sind auch relativ günstig,
Weil ganz im Ernst, 4 Kerne, 8 GB RAM, 6,49 Euro.
Für das gleiche bezahlst du bei Lidl 130 Euro.
Und man kann übrigens auch noch sagen, ich brauche keine IPv4-Adresse, dann ist es sogar noch ein bisschen billiger.
Das macht tatsächlich Sinn.
Ich brauche keine IPv4-Adresse.
Also wenn man da ein bisschen was Größeres aufbaut, sagen wir zum Beispiel jetzt mal, du stellst einen Datenbank-Server hin und du stellst zwei Application-Server hin und vielleicht noch ein Reverse-Proxy davor als Eingang, SSL-Endpunkt oder sowas.
Ich glaube, ich habe keinen Hetzner-Affiliate-Link mehr. Der ist, glaube ich, abgelaufen.
es wäre vielleicht nice, wenn ich
mal demnächst
wieder mehr streame, sich da wieder
neuen zu besorgen, ja
und dann brauchen die Server, die
dahinter stehen ja nicht zwangsläufig
eine Public IPv4 Adresse
das reicht, wenn die eine interne IP
haben, es braucht eigentlich nur euer
Reverse Proxy oder sagen wir mal euer Loadbalancer
davor eine IPv4 Adresse
und ich glaube Loadbalancer selbst bieten sie ja mittlerweile
auch sogar an
So, also, das ist halt preis-leistungsmäßig top. Man kriegt da vielleicht nicht die krasse Hochverfügbarkeit und Enterprise-Hardware unten drunter wie bei den anderen Cloud-Anbietern, aber letztendlich interessiert es mich wirklich großartig, solange die ihre Cloud-Infrastruktur ordentlich managen und hier Performance fürs Geld stimmt, ist mir das ehrlich gesagt ziemlich wurscht, ob das ein billiges ASRock-Mainboard ist.
mit einer Consumer SSD.
Juckt mich nicht.
Worauf das dann letztendlich läuft.
Es sind ja auch VMs, die man kriegt.
Und auch wenn die Verfügbarkeit vielleicht über lange Sicht
nicht ganz so hoch ist wie bei größeren Clouds,
wobei ich das noch nicht mal weiß, ob das so ist.
Also wenn man davon aussehen, dass es vielleicht minimal kleiner ist.
Also den Preis wiegt das nicht auf, aus meiner Sicht.
Und deswegen, Hetzner, was das angeht,
oder es gibt ja noch andere Hoster in der Richtung,
was haben wir denn hier noch, NetCap gibt's
noch und OVH
und was es da nicht alles gibt.
Ist nicht schlecht.
OVH wollte ich mir auch mal einen Server kaufen.
Testweise,
weil ich einfach mal ausprobieren wollte, weil ich auch im Chat
öfters gehört hab, OVH
wäre richtig nice, gute Alternative
auch zu Hetzner und so.
OVH sind die, wo das RZ
vor zwei Jahren oder so mal abgefackelt ist.
Wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren.
und
habe ich mich registriert, wollte einen Server
mieten und da haben die gesagt,
sie bekommen von uns keinen Server,
wenn sie uns nicht
ihren Ausweis
einscannen und per E-Mail
schicken. Da habe ich auch gesagt,
ne.
Ne.
Ganz bestimmt nicht, Alter.
Dann halt
nicht, dann halt nicht, ja.
dann halt nicht
per Mail, ja
dann halt nicht, dann halt nicht
dann geh ich, im Zweifelsfall
wenn gar nichts geht, geh ich halt zu Cloudflare oder so
äh, nicht Cloudflare, sorry, äh
Digital Ocean, mein ich
und ehrlich
wenn die Verifikation machen wollen
Wenn, dann sollen sie halt einen Postident übers Handy machen.
Aber ich scanne doch nicht meinen Ausweis ein und schicke das per Mail.
Also wirklich.
Ich sage also nicht Hetzer, sondern OVH war das bei mir.
Also, ne.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Ich will es jetzt nicht aussprechen.
Wer weiß, ob das gefleckt wird. Was ist das? Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kryptohandys, sagt Wikipedia.
Bedeutet Traffic inklusive, dass wenn man einen HTTP-Server aufstellt und der den ganzen Tag geportscanned wird und von iBots gescaled, dass der Traffic gilt oder nur ausgehend?
Es ist nur in eine Richtung, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, Hetzner hat früher Unterschieden zwischen eingehendem und ausgehendem Traffic.
Vielleicht ist das auch immer noch so.
Naja.
Aber 20TB
musst du auch mit Port Scans erstmal vollkriegen.
Das ist schon einiges.
Preislich ist es wirklich top.
Und was sie mittlerweile auch noch haben,
wenn du keinen x86 Server
brauchst, sondern, wo gibt es denn
eigentlich die
Früher hatten die doch auch ARM Server, oder?
Sind die hier? Gibt es die nicht mehr?
Haben die keine ARM Server mehr?
Die hatten doch mal welche.
Sind die weg wieder?
Anscheinend gibt es hier nicht mehr.
Ach stimmt, Ampere.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Lul.
Ja, ja, ihr habt recht.
Genau, da gibt es hier
Ampere.
Aber guck mal.
Warum ist denn der teurer?
Warum ist denn der teurer
als
der
x86, das x86 Gegenstück.
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Früher waren die günstiger.
Okay.
Und warum sollte ich die dann nehmen?
Gut, vielleicht wenn ich ARM Software
bauen will oder so, aber
das Bildserver, keine Ahnung.
Ich schwarz.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die...
Gut, je nachdem, was für CPUs das sind, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die höhere Performance haben.
Egal.
So, gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
Sind ein wenig sidetracked worden.
Äh, Chat.
Führt das Video nicht mehr.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe eine halbe Stunde geschwätzt.
Ein paar 5 Minuten 30.
Das wird noch was, ey.
Denkbar, wenn auch unwahrscheinlich, ist auch absolut ein Abo für Windows,
denn Daten kann man ja heutzutage mit KI schon künstlich erzeugen und die sind deswegen nicht mehr so wertvoll.
Und wenn es wirklich hart auf hart kommt, dann kann man uns tatsächlich den Saft komplett abdrehen.
Es geht nicht zwingend darum, was auf jeden Fall kommen wird, das weiß niemand.
Es geht um die Möglichkeit, die uns genommen wird.
Warum sollte man sich in unsicheren Zeiten abhängig machen von einem unsicheren, unzuverlässigen, teuren und nicht besseren Anbieter?
Die Antwort ist ganz einfach.
Gewohnheit.
Windows mussten wir auch lernen.
Und nur deshalb nutzen noch so viele Leute...
Das stimmt.
Wobei man halt auch ferneshalber sagen muss, zu vielen Microsoft-Services so richtig gute Alternativen gibt es da halt nicht.
Ich will letztendlich mit Office anfangen.
Ihr wisst, ich benutze selbst so gut wie kein Office.
Das Einzige, was ich von Office ab und zu mal verwende, ist PowerPoint, weil man nicht dran vorbeikommt, wenn man da seine Präsentation einreichen will und was zeigen will. Aber ich verwende ja kein Office. Aber die Leute haben sich, wie er sagt, Gewohnheit. Die Leute haben sich so krass auf Office eingeschossen.
das aus denen wieder rauszukriegen
das wird zumindest bei der Generation
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht mehr funktionieren
und auch was Active Directory angeht
und das Management von
kleinen PCs
ich kenn mich in der Windows Welt nicht aus
aber ich würde jetzt einfach mal
behaupten, dass es immer noch
dem überlegen, was du da unter Linux machen kannst.
Also ich denke, bei vielen Sachen,
oder gerade auch diese Managed Active Directory-Geschichte,
die viele bei Azure verwenden,
ich weiß nicht, ob es da wirklich gute Alternativen zu Microsoft gibt.
Wie heißt das jetzt?
Es heißt ja nicht mehr Active Directory, Azure Active Directory.
Entra-ID heißt das jetzt.
Genau.
Entra-ID.
Ubuntu hat das auch.
Keine Ahnung, wie gut das da ist.
Windows 10. Aber einen Umstieg,
daran kommt man sowieso nicht mehr.
Noch heißt es Entra-ID.
Ja, demnächst heißt es bestimmt Entra-Copilot-App oder so.
Copilot.
Microsoft nennt das komplett anders um.
AI-Copilot-Directory oder sowas.
... dieses Jahr noch.
Um das so zu sagen, für mich war ziemlich klar, dass ich weg will.
Linux hingegen ist Open Source, demnach komplett kostenlos natürlich.
Und wenn hier jemand Spyware einbauen würde,
würden ungefähr mehrere Millionen Nerds und Akteure...
Wenn einer versucht, Spyware zu committen,
wird der erst mal richtig krass von Linus geflamed,
so wie sich das gehört.
Der wird erst mal richtig heftig beleidigt.
das kann man sicher sein.
Weil man jede einzelne Änderung
natürlich sofort sehen kann und
dementsprechend sicher ist das ganze
System auch. Linux ist der Standard
für Server. Was hältst du eigentlich von GCC?
Wieso im Vergleich zu
du kommst halt gerade was
Embedded Sachen angeht, oftmals
an GCC nicht vorbei. GCC ist noch ein bisschen
verbreiteter als
Clang oder, hör mal bloß
auf, wenn ich, Moment, meinst du überhaupt?
Ach Moment, Moment.
Haha, Chad, ich hätte vielleicht mal weiterlesen sollen.
Moment.
Du meinst GCP?
Ah.
Ja, ich habe vorher tatsächlich hauptsächlich mit Error gearbeitet.
Jetzt arbeite ich hauptsächlich mit GCP.
Weil das so halt arbeitgebertechnisch gesetzt ist.
ich habe auch lange gar nichts mehr mit Azure gemacht
es nimmt sich nicht viel, ganz ehrlich
es nimmt sich nicht viel
mittlerweile habe ich mich an das
also am Anfang habe ich ja immer gesagt, mir hat
das
Azure Interface mit diesen zwei
Menüs, die hier neben so ausklappen, viel besser gefallen
als GCP, mittlerweile
muss ich sagen, habe ich mich an GCP gewöhnt
dass ich sagen würde, mir gefällt sogar
GCP besser
aber letztendlich nimmt sich das alles
nicht so viel.
Eigentlich wurscht.
Was viele Firmen dazu zwingt,
regelmäßig sehr genaue Audits laufen.
Bei AWS, was mich bei AWS immer irritiert,
dass die für alles so komische
Namen haben.
...zulassen und die besten Hacker der Welt untersuchen am liebsten, richtig, Linux.
Dadurch wird das ganze System sehr viel stabiler und auch sehr viel sicherer.
Linux als Basis für einen Server ist für die meisten einfach ein Muss.
Und so natürlich auch für unsere freundlichen Partner.
Ganz ehrlich.
Windows Server, wer das machen muss, der muss echt irgendwie so ein bisschen so schisslich veranlagt sein.
ich weiß, es gibt Leute, die damit Geld verdienen,
sich das nicht aussuchen können, aber privat,
wer privat sagt, ich installiere
mir einen Windows-Server, um mein Zeug
laufen zu lassen, also
bei dem muss man
wahrscheinlich psychologisch mal nachforschen,
was da falsch gelaufen ist.
Einen N8N-Server mieten könnt, der
natürlich Linux im Hintergrund
hat. Damit ihr aber nichts selbst
installieren müsst, liefert euch Hostinger den
Server. Selbst Microsoft lässt ihr Kram auf Linux laufen, ja.
Und mit N8N installiert,
plus ein intuitives Dashboard, falls ihr mal...
Hatte NADN nicht letztens auch eine krasse Sicherheitslücke?
Da war doch was.
...einfach alles, was euch in den Sinn kommt.
Per Klicks, nicht per Code automatisieren.
Für mich war es das Teilen von YouTube-Videos
auf Mastodon, Threads, X und Blue Sky,
aber auch das Satieren meiner Mails,
damit ich immer weiß, was eigentlich was ist.
Ihr könnt aber natürlich auch eure E-Mails in Aufgaben verwandeln
und in Notion reinstopfen, euren Home Assistant erweitern,
um euer Smart Home besser mit externen Datenquellen anzurechnen
oder euch einfach jeden Morgen eine Zusammenfassung eures Aktienportfolios schicken lassen.
Das ist die Schönheit an...
Ich gucke einfach mal kurz alle paar Tage in Scalable rein, das reicht mir.
Kann ich sehen, dass meine... Was machen? Wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Chat, wo habe ich mein Handy? Ich muss mal kurz meine Stonks checken.
Habe ich schon eine Woche nicht mehr geguckt?
Sekunde.
So, kurzer Stonks-Check.
So wirklich was getan eigentlich.
Sogar wieder ein bisschen gestiegen.
Hältst den Grenzen.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Letzte Woche.
Minus.
Minus 0,16% letzte Woche.
Na gut.
Ich werde es überleben.
Next.
Weiter gucken.
N8N.
Es ist die Antithese zu einem Ökosystem, wo ihr bei einem Anbieter eingesperrt werdet.
Es befreit euch daraus und verbindet jedes Ökosystem einfach mit jedem anderen.
Ohne, dass ihr programmieren müsst.
Wir gucken uns die Werbung an.
Und genau deshalb feiere ich das so sehr.
N8N selbst ist komplett Open Source und Hostinger setzt mit ihrem Service einfach nochmal einen oben drauf.
Sodass ihr einfach Hostinger habt, die sich um die Infrastruktur kümmern.
Heißt das N8N oder N8N?
Und selbst den Kopf frei habt für das, was wichtig ist.
Deswegen schnappt euch hier neben mir euren eigenen N8N Server bei Hostinger.
Das ist in der Tat eine gute Idee.
... und es gibt nochmal 10% Rabatt mit dem Code oben drauf.
Vielen Dank an Hostinger, dass ihr das Video hier ermöglicht.
Okay, stopp. Ich weiß, was ihr jetzt alle denkt.
Das klingt an sich logisch und politisch wichtig, aber ich habe Angst.
Ich habe Angst vor diesem schwarzen Fenster mit der grünen Schrift.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich Hacker-Man sei.
Das kommt daher, also das haben ja viele Windows-User,
dass sie irgendwie Panik vor der Konsole haben.
Das liegt aber daran,
ich meine jetzt nicht die 0815-Sekretärin oder so,
sondern auch wirklich technisch ein bisschen interessierte Leute,
die haben Angst vor der Konsole.
Und ich bin überzeugt, das liegt daran,
weil die Leute früher,
es gibt ja das alte Terminal-Prompt nicht mehr,
es gibt nur das neue,
weil die Leute das Windows-Terminal
und dieses komische Batch-CLI,
was es da früher gab,
mal in Kontakt gekommen sind.
Und das ist halt einfach nur der größte Shit ever.
Das ist so ein Dreck.
Also sowohl das alte Windows Terminal,
als auch diese Windows Scripting-Sprache da,
das ist so heftig, hardcore für den Arsch,
dass die Leute zu Recht gesagt haben,
boah, nee, damit will ich nie wieder was zu tun haben.
Und die denken jetzt halt, wenn sie den Terminal sehen,
oh, das ist genauso schlimm.
Ja doch, das neue Terminal ist schon deutlich besser.
Das neue Terminal ist deutlich besser.
Du hast Tabs, du kannst hier drinnen Schrift ändern und so was.
Gibt es das alte Terminal eigentlich noch?
Ähm, wir machen mal Chat-GPT.
Äh, kann man das alte Windows-Terminal noch unter Windows 11 öffnen?
Na, oh.
Das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Das ist ChatGPT lügt wieder.
ChatGPT lügt.
System 32 CMD.
Das ist auch das neue.
Lüg nicht, ChatGPT.
Conhost-Exe?
Ja.
Nee.
Das ist auch schon ein bisschen besser.
Da kann man scrollen mittlerweile drinnen.
Das ist nicht was?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ja, doch, doch.
Ja, dieses Ding.
Dieses Ding hier, ja.
Also das ist ja wirklich komplett für den Arsch.
Und auch diese, also LS gibt's natürlich.
Und auch diese Shell, die da drin läuft.
Das ist komplett für den Arsch.
Also da kann ich verstehen, dass die Leute da Angst vorhaben.
Und das Blöde ist, dass viele halt denken jetzt,
wenn sie das unter Linux sehen, die denken,
Oh nein, eine Shell, ganz schlimm, aber das ist mit das Beste, was es gibt. Ich verbringe wahrscheinlich die Hälfte der Zeit, wo ich unter Linux bin, verbringe ich in der Shell. Die andere Hälfte verbringe ich im Browser.
okay,
je nachdem, was ich mache, ja, wenn ich hier
eine IDE zu programmieren auf habe, dann ist es wahrscheinlich
eher 40% IDE
und der Rest dann Dings und
Shell und Browser teilen sich.
Aber wisst ihr was ich meine? Eine ordentliche Shell
ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Das wissen die aber nicht.
Ein Muss, nur um eine PDF zu öffnen.
Fisch habe ich noch nicht, ja doch,
gezwungenermaßen habe ich Fisch ab und zu
schon ein bisschen ausprobiert, aber
ich bin bei
ZSH bei Zisch
hängen geblieben seit Jahren schon. Bin damit
super zufrieden. Ich werde da auch nichts umstellen.
Übrigens, habe ich euch schon
mein neuestes
Fivehead-Alias gezeigt?
Habe ich schon, glaube ich.
Guckt mal.
Known Hose.
Wenn wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel
hier
tun wir mal so,
ja, 55,
wenn ich mich jetzt hier versuche,
auf den,
auf die Kiste zu verbinden,
dann kommt ein Fehler,
weil der sagt, ey,
der Server-Key hat sich geändert.
Das kommt öfters vor,
wenn man Server neu aufbaut.
Was ich jetzt machen müsste,
ist, ich müsste jetzt eigentlich
in die Datei gehen, den Server-Key
löschen oder SSH
keygen-r machen.
Aber was ich mir jetzt gebaut habe,
ich habe mir ein Kommando gebaut, das nennt sich fixsh.
Das gebe ich jetzt einfach ein.
Zack. Und jetzt verbinde ich mich
nochmal und es funktioniert.
Wenn ich mich mit dem richtigen Benutzer
einlogge.
Welchen User
brauche ich denn, Max?
Das ist nice, oder?
Und ich habe mir überlegt,
man könnte das sogar noch
erweitern, dass es das letzte
SSH-Code. Leute, das ist
die Idee. Ich bin ja richtig dumm.
Ich bin ja
richtig dumm. Das können wir doch einfach machen.
Ich hole einfach meine History.
Gap.
Gap nach Anfang
SSH.
Äh.
Chat bin ich doof.
Achso.
Ähm.
Kann man bei der History irgendwie die
Timestamps ausblenden? Egal.
Ansonsten, wir cutten das jetzt.
Ist okay.
Cut.
Okay.
Wir holen uns das einfach aus der History raus.
Pass mal auf.
Ist History minus R?
Gibt's nicht.
egal, wir machen das jetzt mal so,
weil, da könnte ich
jetzt einfach sagen,
History,
Tail minus N1,
N1,
so, History minus
1 und das hier einfach dann nochmal ausführen.
Wie
macht man Eval so?
So.
So. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob das funktioniert, was ich hier gestrickt habe.
Also, wir machen das jetzt
nochmal kaputt.
Wir machen das jetzt nochmal kaputt hier mit dem Key.
Sagen, das hier ist der
Server mit dem Key drin. Zack.
So. SSH.
SSH. Max. Add.
geht. Warum geht das?
Achso, weil der noch drin ist.
Äh, ich glaube nicht.
Hä?
What the fuck?
Okay, geht nicht mehr. Ist kaputt.
So, und jetzt? Pix SSH.
Und wir sind drauf.
Nice!
Das ist ein guter Chat. Ihr habt mich auf eine gute Idee gebracht.
Jetzt führt der einfach das letzte SSH-Kommando nochmal aus, was er gefunden hat.
Das ist super praktisch.
Guck mal, also nur so als Erklärung, wie es funktioniert.
Der holt sich hier aus meinem Terminal den letzten Buffer raus.
Kannst du nochmal erklären, was das jetzt...
Okay, okay.
Ich erkläre es nochmal von Anfang an.
Also, wenn man sich per SSH...
Wenn man jetzt öfter Server neu aufbaut, ja?
mal testet oder so, die Server haben die
gleiche IP, dann meckert
SSH immer rum beim Connecten,
weil sich der Host-Key
vom Server geändert hat. Der ist nach jedem
Neuaufbau anders.
Deswegen meckert SSH. SSH sagt ja auch
zu Recht, ey, guck mal, hinter
dieser IP ist jetzt ein neuer Server,
vorher war da ein anderer. Pass mal auf,
nicht, dass da jemand Man-in-the-Middle
oder irgendwie sowas macht.
Ist ja auch sinnvoll, dass SSH das macht. Wenn man das allerdings
weiß, dass man selbst den Server
neu aufgebaut hat und will das einfach nur ignorieren
beziehungsweise überschreiben,
dann müsste man normalerweise hier
in seine neuen Hosts reingehen,
den Server suchen, hier die IP löschen
und gut ist.
So.
Oder aber SSH, Keygen,
minus R und die IP machen.
Das habe ich automatisiert
mit einer
Shell-Funktion, die sich fix.ssh
nennt und die macht folgendes.
Die holt aus meinem Terminal
den letzten Textbuffer raus.
Also quasi alles, was hier
an Text im Terminal steht.
History tut es an der Stelle nicht.
Also ich brauche wirklich den Text hier aus dem Terminal.
So, der holt sich den Text
aus dem Terminal raus hier mit Westerm CLI
Get Text. Dann crept er
nach dieser Fehlermeldung hier
Hostkey has changed.
Danach crept er
und dann crept er sich noch
das kann man bestimmt noch schöner machen.
Dann crept er sich die IP raus
aus der Fehlermeldung
und dann sagt er,
dann holt er sich
den letzten Match, also
das letzte SSH-Kommando,
was fehlgeschlagen ist, davon
holt er sich die IP raus
und dann übergibt er das an
SSH-Keygen-R und das löscht das
dann. Und dann
sucht er mir aus der History mein letztes
SSH-Kommando raus
und führt das
nochmal neu aus. Und deswegen
kann ich jetzt, wenn das hier
fehlschlägt, die Verbindung, kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, fix
SSH, zack, erlöscht's.
Ich sag, jawoll, neuer Key akzeptieren
und ich bin wieder drauf.
Sehr nice.
Das ist der Chat, hat nämlich auch eine gute Idee gebracht, das noch
zu erweitern damit jetzt.
Wir sind ganze drei Minuten weitergekommen
im Video. Sidetrack des Todes,
das ist er heute.
Aber das ist wirklich
nice, das gefällt mir.
Und genau hier müssen wir
aufräumen. Dieses Vorurteil hält
uns nämlich in der Geiselhaft von Microsoft.
Kleiner Spoiler, ich habe in den
letzten Wochen seltener das Terminal
geöffnet, als unter Windows den
Task Manager, wenn sich mal wieder
Microsoft Teams aufgehängt hatte. Im Gegenteil,
klar, ihr könnt das tun,
aber ihr müsst absolut nicht. Ich schreibe Q-Chat.
Ihr habt eine Desktop-Oberfläche wie unter Windows,
die hat Einstellungen, die könnt ihr anpassen.
Nee, automatisch will ich fix SSH nicht ausführen.
Finde ich schon ganz okay.
Weil es könnte ja sein, dass sich wirklich mal was geändert hat.
Ich will da schon drüber Bescheid wissen.
Man könnte natürlich
irgendwas einbauen, was dann quasi fragt,
hier willst du das jetzt neu versuchen oder sowas.
Aber SSH, so ein Custom Command ist schon ein bisschen eklig,
weil du musst ja so viele Optionen hintendran unterstützen,
da musst du gucken, wie du das in Bash durchreichst.
Ich glaube, so bin ich da schon zufrieden mit.
Im Gegenteil, ich persönlich würde sogar sagen,
unter modernen Linux-Systemen müsst ihr weniger Angst haben,
dass irgendwas nicht läuft.
Wenn man unter Windows Software installiert,
dann müsst ihr häufig ins Internet.
Vieles ist im Microsoft Store gar nicht drin, weil Microsoft...
Der Microsoft Store ist ja auch Schrott.
Moderne Linux-Systeme wie Mint oder Ubuntu haben App-Stores, die aussehen...
Oder CacheOS, wenn man mal aktuelle Hype-Sachen auffasst.
Ihr klickt auf Installieren, fertig.
Keine Setup.exe, keine Treibersuche im Internet.
Nicht mal ein Bitte startet den PC neu, nicht mal dann, wenn ihr System-Updates macht.
Das kann Linux einfach so, während es läuft.
Dementsprechend waren vier meiner Bildschirme...
Außer Kernel-Updates.
Ich hatte die einfach Plug & Play, die habe ich einfach eingesteckt und sie haben funktioniert.
Der fünfte, der Teleprompter um genau zu sein, war ein bisschen komplizierter.
Das Problem ist nämlich, der läuft nur über USB.
Hier musste ich die KI fragen, was genau ich machen soll und danach ging es auch.
Achso, und Maustastatur, mein Audiointerface, die waren auch alle Plug & Play.
Diese Stores brauchen natürlich übrigens keine Anmeldedaten.
Die Software kostet sowieso nichts, weil sie meistens Open Source ist und sie stammt aus der Community.
von Leuten wie mir und vielleicht, falls ihr Bock habt, irgendwann mal von euch.
Und trust me, die Community ist krass.
Wenn man an Windows relativ fest ist, wie das ganze System aussieht,
gibt es in Linux eben zig Plugins, Themes und so weiter und so fort,
alle von der Community für euch erstellt.
Es gibt sogar ein eigenes Subreddit übrigens namens Unix Porn.
Hier ein paar schöne Ausschnitte.
Ich muss aber zugeben, ich persönlich, ich bin einfach.
Ich habe schon lange nicht mehr auf den Discord geguckt, da gibt es auch ein Channel für sowas.
Ich habe mir einfach nur ein Eigenpack runtergeladen und ja, das war's.
Ich bin aber auch nicht der Designer in unserem ganzen Kosmos hier.
Deswegen, ich würde vielleicht meiner Designerin ganz gerne mal Linux vorwerfen.
Das wäre ein ziemlich cooles Experiment.
Aber gutes Aussehen bezahlt natürlich keine Miete.
Und hier kommen wir zu genau dem Knackpunkt, an dem die meisten scheitern.
Die Software. Machen wir uns nichts vor.
Wenn ihr gezwungen seid, originale Word-Dokumente mit speziellen Makros zu bearbeiten
oder ihr Adobe Premiere mietet, dann ist der Umstieg härter.
Was? Adobe Premiere Mietet? Was? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Glücklicherweise geht vieles von Office jetzt ja auch im Browser mit Microsoft 365, aber Native Plugins natürlich nicht.
Ach, Mietet! Mietet! Jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Ich habe an Meeting gedacht.
Miete, ach so.
Siehste mal.
Mieten heißt bei mir, ich mache ein Meeting.
Ist der Umstieg härter.
Nicht unmöglich, aber deutlich härter.
Ich habe meine Videos in den letzten Monaten immer selbst geschnitten.
Mit CapCut.
CapCut kennt der ein oder andere von euch vielleicht als Handy-App, um TikTok-Videos zu schneiden.
Right?
Dafür ist es eigentlich auch gemacht. Es ist einfach und sehr schnell. Es läuft aber auch sehr gut auf dem PC, auf einem Windows-PC.
CapCut läuft hingegen nicht unter Linux. Aber eigentlich ist das gut so.
CapCut hat eine echt widerliche Datenpolicy von einem Tag auf den anderen gedroppt.
Wenn du es weiter nutzen willst, werden alle Videos von dir, die du je geschnitten hast, inklusive deinem Gesicht, für KI-Training genutzt.
Geil.
Cool. Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich gerade drei Videos im Schnitt bei mir, zwei Shorts und ein langes.
Zwei davon schon angefangen und das lange Video mit der Deadline an diesem Tag, wo nur noch eine einzige Änderung nötig war.
Das ablehnen zu können, das muss man sich erstmal erlauben können.
Falls ihr also bald einen KI-Maufer seht, der Werbung für Scamcoins macht, bedankt euch gerne bei CapCut.
Jetzt bin ich umgestiegen auf DaVinci Resolve Studio.
Das läuft auf Linux nicht nur, es ist neben Adobe Premiere der Industriestandard in Hollywood und läuft auf Linux deutlich stabiler.
Da habe ich auch schon ein Auge drauf geworfen.
... als auf Windows.
Es läuft butterweich, flüssig und das letzte Video, das ihr gesehen habt, das zu Frima, das habe ich komplett unter Linux geschnitten.
Viele von euch könnten vielleicht auch Photoshop brauchen.
Und ja, ich muss leider auch der sein, der sagt, ihr könnt auch GIMP nutzen, denn Photoshop läuft nicht auf Linux.
GIMP ist open source und kostenlos, während Photoshop euch über 20 Euro im Monat kostet.
Und seit GIMP 3 das letzte Jahr rauskam, gibt es nichts, was ich in Photoshop gemacht habe, was ich nicht auch in GIMP schaffe.
Großer Pluspunkt, in GIMP kann ich sogar meinen eigenen Code ausführen.
Und für Buchhaltung...
Ich will weder Photoshop noch GIMP. Ich will sowas wie Affinity Designer haben.
Das jetzt nicht mehr so heißt. Das gibt's ja... wurden ja gekauft.
Das läuft sowieso alles heutzutage im Browser.
Der Punkt ist, wir haben uns alle an...
Moin Onkel
Kubik Meta Klaus
auch ein
spezieller Name
gibt es mittlerweile ein Wine Patch
welches die Adobe Installer fix
ja das habe ich gelesen
das habe ich gelesen
gar nicht so lang her
2-3 Wochen
aber was halt nicht geht unter Linux
ist
GPU Beschleunigung
in Wine Programm und so
Wine kann das ja noch nicht
also selbst wenn man es installieren kann also es wird nie so gut sein wie unter
windows aktuell zumindest noch bis wine vielleicht das irgendwann mal
unterstützt
markennamen wie adobe gewöhnt an deren interfaces an das wie die tools aussehen
nicht aber an die tätigkeit selbst linux zwingt uns kurz eben neu zu lernen wie
das Werkzeug heißt und wie es aussieht.
Das habe ich übrigens in meinem Video auch gesagt.
Ich habe ja auch vor ein paar Jahren schon ein Video dazu gemacht, dass es
nicht unbedingt für jeden eine Alternative
ist, Linux zu Windows.
Das ist auch gesagt. Man muss sich
wirklich auch auf was Neues einlassen
wollen.
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum das nicht geht.
Mussten wir eigentlich
damals auch schon lernen. Und
damals haben wir uns dann halt an einen Standard
gewöhnt. Aber sobald man das Muskelgedächtnis
es ein bisschen umtrainiert hat, merkt man eigentlich, Moment mal, warum zur Hölle habe
ich eigentlich jahrelang über 70 Euro im Monat für Creative Cloud gezahlt, wenn Krita
oder GIMP das Ganze kostenlos können.
Für 95% der Menschen findet der digitale Alltag im Browser statt.
Chrome, Firefox, Spotify, Discord, Notion, Netflix, das alles läuft unter Linux exakt
gleich.
Ihr werdet keinen Unterschied merken.
Außer, dass vielleicht der Lüfter eures Rechners ein bisschen seltener anspringt.
Ich habe mich, kann ich euch alles nicht beantworten.
So genau bin ich da nicht drin, was da Wein-mäßig passiert oder Proton-mäßig.
Neulich auch mit einem Insider aus einem DAX-Konzern unterhalten.
Keine Sorge, das wird gleich wieder wichtig für uns.
Er sagte, nehmen wir an, jede Firma in Deutschland gibt Adobe sein Geld.
60 Euro im Monat pro Mitarbeiter.
Also je nach Größe dann doch mal gut und gerne mehr als 100.000 Euro.
Weil man eben Videoschnitt, Bearbeitung von Bildern und so weiter und so fort braucht.
Nehmen wir dann noch dazu, dass mir einer von euch erzählt hat,
er wurde gekündigt, weil seine Firma
kein Geld hat. Besagte Firma
hat aber gleichzeitig mehrere Millionen
im Monat an Lizenzen an Microsoft
gezahlt. Leute, wenn ihr wüsstet,
ich kann das natürlich jetzt nicht im Detail erzählen,
wenn ihr wüsstet, was wir für Lizenzkosten
auf der Arbeit haben. Meine Güte.
Letztens,
noch eine Sache kann ich erzählen.
Letztens kam raus,
also wir benutzen ja auch ab und zu Grafana,
in verschiedenen Projekten
und es gibt auch so eine zentrale
Grafana-Installation und sowas.
Ich habe erfahren,
das ist übrigens ganz normales Grafana,
also kein Enterprise oder so,
aber ich habe erfahren,
die Firma hat eine Grafana
Enterprise Lizenz, die eigentlich
nicht benutzt wird. Und wisst ihr,
was das gekostet hat?
Ich weiß jetzt leider nicht den Zeitraum.
Wahrscheinlich für ein Jahr
oder so.
Sehen wir mal, was das gekostet hat.
180.000 Euro.
Für nix.
Das kam jetzt erst letztens raus.
180.000 Euro.
Also Lizenzkosten
sind teilweise so heftig.
Für Grafana Enterprise.
Ja.
Es ist richtig.
Pepo Burn Money.
und es benutzt auch nicht mal einer
Grafana Enterprise. Wir haben noch nicht mal
Grafana Enterprise installiert.
Es wurde einfach mal gekauft
und jetzt ist aufgefallen,
oh, vielleicht sollten wir es nicht mehr verlängern.
Das kostet 180.000 Euro
im wahrscheinlich Jahr.
Welches Linux?
Also es gibt da drei Sachen, die zur Zeit
also machen wir es mal so.
Das gehypte aktuell
ist eindeutig CacheOS.
Hat auch viele coole Sachen.
Ich habe CacheOS selbst mal kurz angeguckt.
Hat einen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Was ich bei CacheOS wirklich nice fand,
ist auch das schön integrierte mit Snapshot-Backups.
Also CacheOS finde ich,
für das da wie neu das ist, ist das echt ganz gut.
Und wenn du was verwenden willst,
was gerade so richtig angesagt ist, dann CacheOS.
Ansonsten als nächstes, was immer geht,
ist Linux Mint.
Und wenn du was willst, was einfach funktioniert, dann ist Linux Mint nicht verkehrt.
Wobei ich persönlich nicht beurteilen kann, wie gut da beispielsweise Steam und Spiele und so topaktuelle Sachen, weiß ich nicht.
Linux Mint läuft ja auch noch nicht unter Wayland, sondern immer noch unter X.
Glaube ich zumindest. Letztes Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, war das so.
Aber wenn du was willst, was einfach funktioniert für so Desktop-Arbeit, ist Linux Mint auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
So, und das nächste ist, wozu ich jetzt nichts sagen kann, weil ich es noch nicht benutzt habe im größeren Umfang,
was aber auch total oft erwähnt wird als System, was auch gut modern ist, richtig schön maintained und einfach funktionieren soll,
ist tatsächlich Fedora seit ein paar Jahren.
Ich lese das immer wieder, gerade in letzter Zeit auch auf Reddit total oft, dass die Leute sagen, ey, wenn es einfach funktionieren soll, mit einer modernen Oberfläche KDE, einfach Fedora.
Platinzan, danke schön für den Sub. Exzellentes Subscription.
also sind die drei sachen cash os fedora oder mit je nachdem so ein bisschen also wenn du
schwerpunkt auf top performance gaming legst dann wahrscheinlich eher cash ios wenn es einfach nur
klassisch funktionieren soll mit wenn es modern sein soll und funktionieren soll dann fedora
Ist Mint nicht einfach nur die Shell?
Nee.
Mint ist eine Distribution auf Basis von,
ich glaube mittlerweile,
Debian mittlerweile schon oder immer noch Ubuntu?
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Vielleicht auch beides?
Besside ist auch eingestellt worden.
Gestern oder so.
Oder Basit, wie auch immer das auch ist.
Das gibt es doch nicht mehr.
Habe ich letztens gelesen.
Wurde das nicht eingestellt?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Moment, Moment.
Oder auch nicht.
Hä? Ich habe doch letztens irgendwas...
Ich habe doch da letztens was zu gelesen.
Bin ich jetzt total verwirrt?
Das hieß ja irgendwie Postmortem oder so.
Ja.
Ich hab nur den Titel gelesen.
Ich dachte, das heißt
Besit gibt's nicht mehr.
Siehste mal, so einfach kann's gehen, wenn man einfach nur den Titel liest.
Also keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich dann ist.
Kein Schimmer.
Vielleicht ist auch nur der Gründer abgehauen.
Ich hab die Überschrift gelesen und dachte, Besserheit gibt's nicht mehr.
Aber vielleicht stimmt's doch nicht.
CentOS wurde eingestellt, ja, das stimmt.
Also CentOS ist jetzt nicht mehr klassisches CentOS.
Proxmox? Proxmox probieren wir demnächst im Stream aus.
Auf meine neue Nasskiste.
Heißt, wer dabei sein will, jetzt am besten followen.
Bisschen sellout muss sein.
als Spende an Gimp und Krita. Dann können die sich davon finanzieren und weiterentwickeln.
Und wenn nun der Firma eine Funktion fehlt, hat die halt einfach einen Softwareentwickler,
der am Gimp-Projekt selbst direkt mitarbeitet und selbst den Code dort programmiert. Das kann jeder,
Open Source. Und der erstellt dann die Funktion. Das kann jeder, der kann. Ja.
Stellt sie allen zur Verfügung. Dieser besagte Mensch bei dem DAX-Konzern meinte,
Dadurch kann man fast schon garantieren,
dass Open Source in nur einem einzigen Jahr
an den kommerziellen Firmen vorbeizieht.
Dann ist ein Tipping Point erreicht.
Dann ist es nicht mal mehr nur günstiger, Open Source zu nutzen,
sondern qualitativ auch schlauer.
Dadurch kommen immer mehr und es werden für jeden...
Da musst du dich wahrscheinlich mit Linux erstmal mit Wayland rumärgern,
wenn du da ein paar Sachen programmieren willst.
Weil Wayland dann erstmal sagt, nee, nee, das ist by Design, das geht ja nicht.
...und vorhanden sein.
Und mit Linux ist das eigentlich schon so. Und Microsoft weiß das übrigens. In Microsoft gibt es sogar eine extra Funktion, die ein Linux in Microsoft installiert, weil so vieles eigentlich nur unter Linux läuft. Die habe ich dringend gebraucht früher. Nennt sich Windows Subsystem Linux. Oder Blender, der de facto Standard für viele, die 3D-Modelle entwerfen wollen. Nicht obwohl, sondern gerade weil es Open Source ist. Nicht nur ist es gratis, es hat auch viele offene Funktionen als viele Konkurrenten.
Und jetzt der Teil, bei dem man früher...
BSL gibt es bei uns nicht auf der Arbeit.
Das ist zu modern, glaube ich.
Ich habe Erfahrung.
Was ist also eigentlich mit Gaming?
Früher war Gaming auf Linux eher etwas, wofür man gemobbt wurde.
Ein schlechter Witz oder zumindest arschkompliziert.
Aber mittlerweile geht das ganz gut.
Das Ding hier hat alles verändert.
Valve hat mit dem Steam Deck und Proton eine Übersetzungsschicht gebaut,
die fast jedes Windows-Spiel nahtlos auf Linux laufen lässt.
Elden Ring lief zum Release auf Linux deutlich flüssiger als auf Windows.
Das ist kein Witz.
Und das ist bei weitem nicht das Einzige gewesen.
Ich zocke hier drauf, beziehungsweise auf meinem Linux-Rechner natürlich,
meine gesamte Bibliothek und habe noch kein einziges Game entdeckt,
das ich wirklich selbst spiele, das nicht läuft.
Wie gesagt, Anti-Cheat. Anti-Cheat ist eigentlich das einzige große Problem.
Im Gegenteil, während ich unter Windows Ubisofts Kacksoft beinstallieren musste und wirklich eine Weile gebraucht habe, bis Anno lief, überspringt Steam auf Linux einfach diesen Schritt.
Es gibt eine einzige schlimme Ausnahme.
Spiele mit aggressivem Kernel-Anti-Cheat wie League of Legends, Valorant oder Fortnite, die kriegt ihr nicht zum Laufen.
Das liegt aber daran, dass diese Spiele tiefen Zugriff auf euer...
Ich glaube Battlefield, Rainbow Six und so Zeug, das wahrscheinlich mit Warzone auch nicht funktionieren.
Warte ich jetzt mal.
diese Spiele komplett zu meinen.
Aber das muss ehrlich gesagt jeder für sich entscheiden.
Aber natürlich kriegt ihr die unter Linux nicht zum Laufen.
Linux lässt das nicht mit sich machen.
Aber kommen wir zurück zu meinem Frankenstein-Setup.
Fünf Monitore, Capture Card, Stream Deck.
Funktioniert das?
Naja, die Bildschirme hatten wir ja schon.
Die Capture Card, die diesmal extern via USB angeschlossen ist,
funktioniert auch, macht aber manchmal kleinere Probleme,
wie das, was ihr im letzten Stream gesehen habt.
Hier musste ich tatsächlich auch mal KI befragen,
dass die sich das mal genauer anschaut.
Und ich hatte ja in dem Video zu KI-Betriebssystemen schon mal ein bisschen drauf angespielt, aber Cloud Code kann extrem gut solche Fehler finden und dann reparieren.
War wohl was mit den Stromspareinstellungen, dass der USB sich zurücksetzt.
Aber dennoch ganz anders als die Elgato Capture Card, die generell...
Das ist ein nices Gehäuse. Ich finde diese Beulenoptik vorne ganz cool.
Hier vorne sieht es ein bisschen aus wie mein Fractal-Design.
Also ich habe ja so ein Meshify-Gehäuse.
Das sieht vorne fast genauso aus.
Ich habe auch ein Meshify.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das sieht meinem sogar ein bisschen ähnlich.
Ah, okay, dann ist es einfach eine neuere Version von meinem Gehäuse.
...einfach nicht unter Linux lauffähig ist, weil Elgato sich weigert, irgendwie Treiber dafür zu machen.
Nun gut, die aktuelle Capture Card ist aber nicht nur günstiger gewesen, sondern eigentlich auch besser.
4K bis zu 144 Hertz.
Das ist mehr, als meine riesige Kamera eigentlich kann.
Und lustigerweise ist die Qualität, wie ich finde, sogar ein bisschen besser unter Linux.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wieso...
Was hat er denn für eine Capture Card?
Aber sie läuft flüssiger. Das Stream Deck hingegen hat auch ein bisschen Sonderbehandlung gebraucht, weil auch von Elgato und Elgato mag Linux nicht.
Aber die Community hat auch hier Lösungen gebaut, die teilweise mächtiger sind als die Originalsoftware.
Ich nutze jetzt Stream Deck UI dafür. Das heißt, leider kriege ich den Elgato Store nicht wie unter Windows, aber dafür kann ich mir einfach eigene Skripte schreiben, die alles für mich machen.
Ich bin hier noch am Arbeiten, aber eins davon wechselt mir zum Beispiel von Kopfhörer auf Boxen und umgekehrt.
Ich kann alles anpassen, wie ich das brauche.
Oh, und ich habe die natürlich nicht selbst geschrieben.
Die Skripte, das war KI.
Cloud Code, wieder mal, um ganz genau zu sein, das kann das wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Es ist einfach diese Freiheit, die mich persönlich sehr süchtig und glücklich macht.
Wenn etwas nicht passt, wird es einfach passend gemacht.
Nicht von einer Firma, die meine Daten will, sondern von einer Community, die Probleme lösen will.
Und alles wird einfach anderen zur Verfügung gestellt.
Man kann es sich herunterladen, dann nochmal für sich anpassen, wenn man das möchte, ganz eben auf die eigenen Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten.
Und weil ich ein kleiner Nerd bin, habe ich sogar noch einen Schritt weiter das Ganze getrieben.
Ganz kurz, das ist Endlevel, das empfehle ich nicht den Anfängern unter euch.
All diese Themen hier sind eigentlich so krass fortgeschnitten, sollen aber zeigen, was alles möglich ist.
Aber auch für euch habe ich gleich was. Stay with me.
Ich habe mich für NixOS diesmal entschieden.
Und ja, es kommt tatsächlich...
Jetzt will er es aber wissen, Alter!
...von nichts, also nix.
Das müsst ihr euch nicht merken, aber das Konzept dahinter ist geil.
Und vielleicht die Zukunft von Computern generell, wenn ihr mich fragt.
Stellt es euch so vor.
Euer PC ist ein Videospiel.
Jetzt will er es wissen, Alter.
Bevor ihr einen Bosskampf macht oder ein kritisches Update in diesem Fall installiert,
speichert das Spiel ganz von selbst.
Bei NixOS ist mein gesamter Computer eine einzige Text...
Also die Sache fand ich bei CacheOS auch nice.
Der macht bei jedem Package-Update und Package-Manager-Zeug,
macht er einen BTFS-Snapshot.
Beta, Butter, FS, keine Ahnung, wie man das genau ausspricht.
Einen Snapshot, den du, auch wenn das Betriebssystem kaputt ist,
über den Boot-Manager zurückrollen kannst.
Mega nice.
Datei.
Wenn ich etwas installiere, wird ein neuer Speicherstand für mich angelegt.
Wenn ich morgen meinen PC starte und irgendein Update hat alles kaputt gemacht, dann wähle ich beim Start einfach gestern aus und zack, mein PC ist exakt so, wie er gestern war.
Also alles davon. Das ist eine Unzerstörbarkeit, die mir kein Windows der Welt geben kann.
Wenn die Wohnung hier abbrennt und ich mir einen neuen Laptop kaufe, kopiere ich da einfach meine Konfigurationsdatei drauf, die natürlich in meinem Backup liegt, drücke Enter und 20 Minuten später ist mein gesamtes digitales Leben wieder da.
Inklusive Wallpaper, Passwörter, Browser-Tabs und Programm.
Ich weiß, das klingt jetzt alles wahnsinnig viel.
Das alles sind einfach nur Möglichkeiten.
Heute Nudeln mit Lachs.
Nee, heute keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute, was gibt's denn heute?
Ähm, ich glaub Reis.
Mit Hähnchen?
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr so sicher.
Auf jeden Fall Reis. Reis gibt's heute.
... tatsächlich mehr meinen Weg zu meinem aktuellen Linux hinzeigen.
NixOS ist eine von hunderten Versionen von Linux.
Und genau deshalb habe ich auch was für euch gebaut.
Wir Nerds neigen ein bisschen dazu, Anfänger mit Fachbegriffen zu erschlagen.
Und ich habe mich hier versucht zurückzuhalten.
Aber nimm Arsch! Nein, nimm NixOS!
Das hilft niemandem.
By the way, Arsch, Beste.
Ich habe eine kleine Website geschrieben, einen Linux-Wahl...
Ja, also ich war die letzten paar Wochen tatsächlich ganz kurz davor, mal ein Update-Video zu machen, was so aussieht.
Schön fetter Clickbait-Titel.
Aber irgendwie kann ich mich noch nicht dazu durchringen.
Weil auf YouTube ist die Reichweite halt auch größer.
Also egal, ob ich darüber reden will auf YouTube.
Ihr beantwortet ein paar simple Fragen, wie zum Beispiel, wollt ihr zocken?
Habt ihr einen alten Laptop oder einen High-End-P...
Wenn, das hat er gevibe-coded, dieses Interface.
Ich wette mit euch, das hat er vibecoded.
...wollt ihr, dass es so aussieht wie Windows oder eher wie Mac.
Und am Ende spuckt euch das Tool eine Empfehlung aus.
Direkt mit Download-Link zum direkten Auslegen und natürlich einer kleinen Anleitung.
Kostenlos und ohne Tracking logischerweise.
Einfach nur als Hilfe für den ersten Schritt.
Den Link findet ihr direkt hier unten bzw. in der Videobeschreibung.
Wichtig ist aber immer, es gibt kein richtig und kein falsch.
Doch, es gibt falsch.
Weil Arch ist das einzig Richtige.
Sind wir uns einig, Leute, oder?
Für Anfänger beispielsweise, die gerne zocken,
würde ich vielleicht PopOS mal als Empfehlung aussprechen.
Das kennen viele gar nicht, ist aber mega.
Stellt es euch wie Pizza vor.
Ich liebe Pizza mit Ananas drauf.
Ich liebe aber auch Mais auf meiner Pizza.
Und manche würden mich dafür töten.
Aber am Ende muss ich das essen.
Und ich judge euch nicht dafür,
wenn ihr vier verschiedene Käsesorten draufpackt,
von denen ich nicht eine essen kann, ohne danach stundenlang Reels scrollen zu müssen.
Belassen wir es dabei.
Das alles sind Möglichkeiten und Freiheiten, die ihr unter Windows und auch unter Mac oftmals nicht habt.
Und wenn euch etwas fehlt, stehen die Chancen relativ gut,
dass entweder irgend so ein Nerd wie ich was gebastelt hat für euch
oder dass irgendeine Firma da draußen dasselbe Bedürfnis hatte und deshalb sowas veröffentlicht hat.
Gratis und ohne Streams attached.
Also ich sage jetzt nochmal das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe.
Wir waren noch nie so nah am Jahr des Linux-Desktops dran wie 2026.
Und wahrscheinlich werden wir auch 2027 noch nie so nah.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich denke nicht,
dass es jemals das Jahr des Linux-Desktops geben wird,
sondern einfach das Schleichend kommt.
Was ist das?
Cyberangriff hautnah, gezielt professionell.
So arbeiten ethnische Hacker.
Okay.
Dann zeig mal her.
Die ethnischen Hackermans.
Ja, sehe ich auch so, habe ich auch am Anfang gesagt.
Also ich denke, es hat zwei große Sachen,
dass Linux aktuell auch so einen Hype hat
und auch wir so nah dran sind dieses Jahr wie noch nie.
Das liegt daran, dass Microsoft Windows extrem verkackt,
ethisch, nicht ethnisch, stimmt, hast recht,
dass Microsoft extrem verkackt bei Windows
und dass auch größere YouTuber wie PewDiePie
und so da jetzt ein bisschen drauf aufgesprungen sind.
Diese zwei Sachen machen es, glaube ich, aus.
Eine Stadt in Rheinland-Pfalz.
Es ist 8 Uhr morgens.
Normaler Betrieb in dieser Bäckerei.
Frische Ware, Kaffee, Dufu.
Wollen wir uns jetzt nicht erzählen, die hacken die Bäckerei oder was.
Ich meine, für die meisten Bäckereien, wenn du da an die Systeme drankommst,
da musst du wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal dich groß anstrengen.
Die sind wahrscheinlich mit Passwort 123456 geschützt.
Also bei einer Bäckerei erwarte ich da jetzt nicht sonderlich viel.
... lufterste Kunden. Alles wie immer. Aber niemand ahnt, in diesem Moment läuft ein Angriff auf die Firma. Gezielt, professionell, geplant.
Gut von uns, schlecht ist das Leben.
Und diese beiden stecken dahinter. Im Musik, Alter.
Immanuel und Janis sind ethische Hacker. Sie brechen in Firmen ein. Ganz legal.
Ja, außer das ist...
Wie hießen die?
Ah, hab ich vergessen.
Die, die jetzt pleite sind angeblich.
Die, die, die...
Wo ich auch ein Video zugemacht hab.
Bin ich blöd? Wie hießen die nochmal?
Mein letztes Video auf YouTube.
Also, bis jetzt.
Hier, die hier. Solutions.
Irgendwas mit Solutions. Modern Solutions.
Jetzt hab ich's wieder.
Ja, die haben da was dagegen, wenn sie auf Sicherheitslücken hingewiesen werden.
Im Auftrag der Geschäftsführung starten die beiden einen sogenannten Penetrationstest.
Sie simulieren einen Cyberangriff. Das Ziel, Schwachstellen finden, bevor es echte Angreifer tun.
Umgangsmachtig Pentesting oder Penetrationstesting bedeutet, dass man kontrolliert in Systeme von außen, von innen, über physische, technische, organisatorische oder im Faktor Menschwege eindringt.
Cyberangriffe sind längst keine Science Fiction mehr. Sie treffen Krankenhäuser, Verwaltungen.
Die zeigen immer gerne in solchen Beiträgen blinkendes Netzwerkequipment.
Wie echte Angreifer gehen auch Pentester kreativ vor.
Letztendlich schaut man sich erst mal an, wie die Firma tickt.
Ist das eine Dudeskultur?
Wie muss ich die ansprechen?
Wie sind die generell drauf?
Dann schaut man mal, finde ich auf Social Media vielleicht schon
irgendwelche Mitarbeiterausweise, dass ich mir vielleicht auch einen
Ausweis kopiere von dem Unternehmen selbst und mich als neuer Mitarbeiter
ausgebe.
Hier sieht man es so aus, als würden einige Fahrer kommen.
Die Phase 1 ist Informationsbeschaffung.
Ich gucke mir erstmal an, was für Informationen finde ich über das Opfer, über den Online-Shop, über die Stadt, über den Mensch.
Die Phase 2 ist, dass ich mit den gewonnenen Informationen schaue, wo kann ich eindringen, was sind die sogenannten Angriffsvektoren.
Etwa zwei Drittel der Unternehmen sehen sich laut einer Studie einer konkreten Gefahr aus.
Ich glaube, an die Tafel schreiben die einzig und allein jetzt nur für den Beitrag.
Danach kommt die Phase, dass man quasi...
Was ist denn das für ein unbequemer Stuhl, Alter?
Wobei, vielleicht ist das gar nicht unbequem. Das sieht aber unbequem aus!
Danach kommt die Phase, dass man quasi mit den Informationen, quasi den Türen und Fenstern,
durch die man durchgeht, auch wirklich kontrolliert eindringt. Man nennt das Exploiting.
Aber Chat, Chat, weil ich hier gerade OSINT lese, hat jemand schon mal mit OSINT wirklich
was Sinnvolles rausgefunden?
Also OSINT ist so ein Suchtool,
wo quasi offene oder
öffentlich verfügbare Quellen
angezapft werden nach Sachen,
die du halt finden willst. Hat da jemand
schon mal was Sinnvolles mitgefunden?
Moment, gab's nicht? Moment, Moment.
Dann verwechsel ich das jetzt. OSINT-Tool,
da hab ich doch letztens...
Doch, klar ist das ein Tool. GitHub.
Äh...
Wie hieß das nochmal?
Das habe ich jetzt...
Das habe ich verwechselt.
Wie hieß denn das nochmal?
Ähm...
Ich habe letztens eins davon benutzt.
Warte mal.
Äh...
Ich muss mal in meine Twitter-DMs gucken.
Haben wir drüber geschrieben.
Mike Red.
Wie ist das?
Äh, GitHub.
Das da.
Hier.
Das ist ein OS, so rum war das, ein OSint-Tool.
das ist euch sucht quasi öffentlich verfügbare
Informationen nach
Dingern, die man
suchen möchte, ja, das ist ein
OS Intuit, das habe ich jetzt verwechselt
mir ist auch gerade der Name nicht eingefallen
muss extra noch hier meine DMs gucken
ja, das habe ich
letztens benutzt
um was zu suchen, ich habe nichts sinnvolles bei
gefunden
Erzähl uns, was du mit dem Thema Cybercrime in der Welt machst.
Volksquote des Teams nach eigenen Angaben 100%.
Es gibt nichts auf der Welt,
was als Schattenwirtschaft so schnell wächst wie Cyberkriminalität.
Es gibt nichts auf der Welt, womit so schnell so viel Geld verdient wird.
Wäre Cybercrime eine Weltwirtschaft, wäre es die drittgrößte der Welt.
Das Team macht sich auf den Weg.
Ihr Ziel? In die Zentrale des Bäckereibetriebs eindringen, Zugang bekommen, Daten abgreifen.
Schaffen Sie es als Angreifer sogar, die ganze Firma lahmzulegen?
Oh, was jetzt? Chat?
Der Browser ist kaputt.
Oh, mein Browser hat...
Ja, was jetzt?
Mit Linux wäre das nicht passiert wahrscheinlich.
Chat sagt, ich soll lieber
der Harvester.
Das kenne ich auch.
Der Harvester. Das kenne ich auch.
Und Malte Go
habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ist Malte Go auch was,
was es auf
GitHub gibt?
Oder ist es irgendein Paid Service?
Maltego.
GitHub. Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Gibt es nicht auf GitHub.
Gibt es auf. Aber bei Kali ist es mit dabei.
Muss man payen.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Interessant.
So, jetzt kommen wir aber das Video mal fertig.
Adrenalin ist mit verbunden, man spürt das Herzschlagen.
Was?
Von daher ist es auch immer sehr viel Adrenalin mit verbunden, man spürt das Herzschlagen.
Naja, wenn der Hackermann erstmal so richtig loslegt.
Alles auf einem Gelände, rund um die Uhr in Betrieb.
Direkt vor der Großbäckerei stellt das Team ungehindert das Auto ab.
Immer häufiger gibt es auch wirklich Vorfälle, dass Angreifer durch eine Tür reingehen,
ziehen sich Festplatten raus und hauen wieder ab.
Hier erstmal nicht, aber...
Ich hab mal gerade was heißes, oder?
Ist zu einfach.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, erstmal mit den Tests Scheibe einschlagen und in die Rechnung stellen.
Wobei, ne, die sind ja von denen beauftragt.
Mit geöffnetes Fenster schon sind die Pentester in der Firma.
Der erste Schritt geschafft. Zutritt bekommen.
Auf Nachfragen der Mitarbeitenden sind die Pentester vorbereitet.
Hi, wir gucken nur nach dem Wechselmakturkamm.
Ja, mach.
Ja.
Der nächste Schritt, digital Zugriff erhalten. In wenigen Minuten haben sie Zugang zum internen Netzwerk.
Wir können auch hier auf unser Vektor alles erreichen.
In der Verwaltung bleiben Rechner oft unbeaufsichtigt. Ein so schneller Zugriff, laut Emanuel, kein Einzelfall.
Viele denken sich, das kann ja nicht passieren, weil wer traut sich denn da reinzugehen und sowas.
Der erste Haken ist, dass wir über den Raspberry Pi von außen Parallel-Institutes ins Haus haben.
Gut für uns, schlecht für das Unternehmen.
Der erste Meilenstein erreicht. Die Angreifer könnten jetzt Befehle von extern auf dem System ausführen.
Es sind relativ wenig Leute da.
Tagsüber steht die Produktion dieser Großbäckerei still.
Alle im Homeoffice.
Teigzubereitung, Gärprozesse und
Backzyklen. Alles ist digital
gesteuert.
Angreifer können so in den Herstellungsprozess
eingreifen.
Ach, ist das der Mr. Robot Soundtrack?
Den Mr. Robot konnte ich mir nicht weiter angucken
nach der ersten Staffel. Ich weiß, der Chat hat
mir schon ein paar Mal gesagt, lohnt sich richtig.
Aber ehrlich, ich fand
Mr. Robot die erste Staffel
zur Hälfte fand ich die mega geil.
Aber danach ging es ja nur noch um irgendwelche
psychischen Macken. Da habe ich selbst genug.
Die da, die da Haupt...
der Maincharakter hat.
Das ging mir dann irgendwann auf den Sack, da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Und dann habe ich
Mr. Robot nie weiter geguckt.
Die Pentester haben
problemlos Zutritt bekommen.
Jetzt nehmen sie sich die elektronischen
Sicherheitsräume im Keller vor.
Viele Systeme sind veraltet,
schlecht abgesichert.
Wir haben hier einen Gimnaz-Faseranschluss.
Das ist ein 6er im Lotto.
Das Schöne ist, wir haben sogar noch...
Moment, jetzt habe ich nicht gewusst, wie sind die da reingekommen?
So in den Herstellungsprozess eingreifen. Die Pentester haben problemlos Zutritt bekommen.
Jetzt nehmen sie sich die elektronischen Sicherheitsräume im Keller vor. Viele Systeme sind veraltet, schlecht abgesichert.
Da gibt es einen Glasfaseranschluss. Das ist ein 6er im Lotto. Das Schöne ist, wir haben sogar noch Solar-Mos.
Das ist ein Wechsel, das heißt, es ist Energieversorgung plus der Hauptzugang mit Glasfaser.
Jetzt könnten sie alles steuern. Temperatur, Rezeptur bis hin zum Stillstand auf Knopfdruck.
Das heißt, wir könnten mit Jahrfall das gesamte Unternehmen über den Grasfaser
zugang und Aufwand lehnen. Als letztes nehmen sie sich die Produktionshallen vor.
Ja so richtig krass, wollte ich gerade auch sagen, Cryonics, so richtig krasses
Gehackere habe ich da jetzt noch gar nicht gesehen.
auch ganz unauffällig dass sie da mit der kamera rumlaufen
Vielleicht ist es auch nachgestellt für den Beitrag.
... ihre neue Rolle. Wartungsmitarbeiter für die Anlage.
Hallo.
Muss doch irgendwo ein Wartungspot sein.
Die laufen ja rum, ist Gesundheitsamt.
Problemlos auf der Zutritt in die Auslieferung.
Um diese Uhrzeit ist es dort noch ruhig.
Doch hier eine der größten Sicherheitslücken.
Schlüssel zu allen Türen.
Unbewacht.
Rasterstein, Drehwagen, Gartentor.
Wir haben alle Filialen. Und?
RFID-Chips.
Ich kann das jetzt einfach.
RFID, read, save, emulate.
Ja, auch können jetzt benutzen.
Nicht gesichert, der Datenspeicher der Firma.
Sensible...
Das ist der Datenspeicher.
Ein 4-Bay-NAS irgendwo am Arsch der Welt.
Informationen zum Mitnehmen.
Machst das Tor hoch, gehst da rein, holst die Daten, gehst wieder raus.
Tschüss.
Die Musik dabei, ey.
Am nächsten Tag, Präsentation der Ergebnisse.
Die Liste der Schwachstellen ist lang.
Offene Türen und Zugänge, ungeschützte PCs.
Die Geschäftsführer sind überrascht, sehen aber auch das Gute.
Grundsätzlich hat erst mal keiner einen Fehler gemacht, sondern hat einfach das Bewusstsein
nicht dafür da und wir haben Potenzial aufgedeckt, die wir heben können.
So kann man es natürlich auch formulieren.
Das ist es für uns eigentlich. Also ich sag mal ganz nüchtern und unemotional,
es ist einfach so, dass wir wissen, woran wir jetzt arbeiten müssen.
Okay, das heißt, sie wird sich nichts tun.
Es gibt nur die Konsequenz, dass man darüber redet, dass man Schlüsse draus zieht und dass
man eben daraus vielleicht Schulungen ableitet für alle anderen, dass eben sowas nicht mehr vorkommt.
Der Pentest ein Weckruf und eine Chance. Denn nur wer weiß, wo die Schwächen liegen,
kann sich schützen. Da kommt jetzt als Order direkt kein Homeoffice mehr, weil ihr müsst vor Ort sein,
dass ihr mitkriegt, wenn jemand einbricht. Uns ist nicht nur wichtig, gut hacken zu können und
Schwachstellen zu finden, sondern eigentlich eher der Effekt, wo wollen wir damit hin?
Wie schaffen wir es, nachhaltig quasi digitale Resilienz zu schaffen?
Und wie schaffen wir es mit dem Know-how, was wir im Hacking haben, die Menschen aufzuschlauen,
zu befähigen?
Aufzuschlauen ist auch eine tolle Frage.
Der Geschäftsführung, dem IT-Leiter, Informationen und Know-how an die Hand zu geben, dass sie
selber hinterher resilient weiterarbeiten können.
Ein Penetrationstest ist kein Angriff.
Erst Verteidigung
Mit den Mitteln der
Da war jetzt echt sehr wenig Gehecke dabei
Die sind da reingelaufen
Haben Zeug geklaut
Erst mal die Pi angeschlossen
Naja
So spannend war das jetzt nicht
Was haben wir ansonsten noch hier?
75...
Was ist das denn? Wo davon?
Wie, ich krieg mehr Upload?
Ja, also die hätten ja mal
zumindest hier wenigstens
einmal C-Matrix starten können, ja?
Jetzt wird das Stream gleich super pixelig,
weil der Encoder das nicht mag.
Oder meine bevorzugte Sache
eigentlich eher das ASCII-Quarium.
Das wirkt noch viel mehr Hackerman.
Weil wer guckt sich Fische schon auf der
Kommandozeile an.
SL, SL ist auch nicht schlecht.
Wie? Nicht installiert?
Ja.
Nee, Hollywood
habe ich nicht mehr installiert.
Oder habe ich noch?
Naja, hab ich nicht mehr.
Das muss ich mal kurz gucken, weil ich will checken, ob ich mehr Upload kriege.
Vodafone Kabel 75 Mbit, ich hab nur 50.
Upload ab Februar, reicht das?
Mega Bit pro Sekunde.
Na, reichen wird das schon, ja.
Upload. Das klingt für die einen nach einem riesen Schritt, für die anderen nach viel zu wenig.
Vodafone schaltet ab Februar...
Aber du bist doch dran, was man machen will.
... und verspricht 24 Millionen Kabelhaushalten in Deutschland schnellere Uploads.
Aber was steckt wirklich dahinter und wie viel bringt das in der Praxis?
Die Antwort ist komplizierter als...
Da brauche ich ein bisschen Hintergrundmusik.
Da tut sich sonst nichts.
...gedacht und sie zeigt, warum Kabel-Internet trotz hoher Download-Raten seit Jahren ein strukturelles Problem hat.
denn während Glasfaseranschlüsse längst 500 oder sogar 1000 Megabit im Upload bieten,
kämpft das Kabelnetz noch immer mit den Grundlagen.
In diesem Video schauen wir uns an, was die DOCSIS 3.1 Low Split Technologie eigentlich ist,
warum der Upload beim Kabelnetz so eine Achillesferse ist
und ob die 75 Megabit pro Sekunde wirklich einen Unterschied machen.
Ey, das hört mich nicht. Ich will nur wissen, ob ich das auch kriege.
weiß man nicht okay da nicht haben wir hier ich spreche einfach hier in telegram auf meinem
handy beantwortet mal die nervigsten mails von der chefredaktion träume meinen download ordner
auf und schicke meiner freundin in netten nachricht in disco und während ich gemütlich
auf dem Rad rumfahre. Das geht
angeblich wirklich mit OpenClaw
aka Moldbot, aka
Claudebot, der, wie ich neulich las,
gefährlichsten Software
der Welt. Und das ist wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mal so falsch, aber dafür ist OpenClaw
auch ziemlich aufregend.
Vielleicht habt ihr den Hype schon mitbekommen.
Ja, wenn schon, dann nur auf eigener VM.
Und installiere das live on tape
ungeschnitten und wir gucken mal zusammen,
was da dran ist an diesem
neuen, ich regle dir dein ganzes Leben
voll automatisch Assistenten. Und was
daran so gefährlich sein soll mit dem Macher Peter Steinberger aus Wien habe ich auch gesprochen.
Richtiger Macher.
Was the most insane thing that I can do, habe ich halt einen Public Discord gemacht und
hab da mein Bot mit Full Access reingehängt.
Das schlägt mir ein bisschen in den Magen, weil es ist einfach nicht fertig.
Es ist drei Monate Arbeit.
Ganz viele Apps werden da quasi de-regulated zu APIs, was den Großen eigentlich gar nicht
schmeckt.
Das ist schon krass.
Ja, ein bisschen Skynet gebaut.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer und lieber Open-Claw-Server, der da hinten steht.
Ich lasse dich heute Abend an.
Du darfst heute aufbleiben.
Aber bitte tu mir den Gefallen und löscht nicht alles.
Und gib nicht all mein Geld aus.
Ein bisschen Angst habe ich ja da vorne.
Naja.
Ja, wenn ihr häufiger 3003 guckt, dann habt ihr das...
Ach, nur neue Verträge.
Ist ja doof.
Ich habe schon öfter gehört.
für viele noch die das gibt jetzt jetzt ernst wir installieren jetzt hier diese gefährlichste
software der welt also die ki die wirklich dinge tut ist hier der untertitel auf der
mod-bots seite wir haben eine konsole offen hier auf dem blanken fedora rechner und test
rechner da sind auch keine wichtigen privaten daten oder so und hier ist mod bot die webseite
So, und hier unten, ja, ist hier die beliebte One-Liner-Installation über ein Shell-Skript.
Das ist ja alle Leute immer...
Naja, wenn schon direkt nach Bash... Wisst ihr was? Wenn schon nach Sudo-Bash-Pipen, ja.
Sehr gerne mögen, weil man weiß nicht genau, was passiert, aber...
Vertrau, ne?
Mold-Bot, kein Problem. Hier kann man auch, wenn man auf Change drückt, kann man hier auch auf Windows...
Die Website ist bestimmt auch wipecoded.
Das Ding auch unter Windows auch mal installieren.
Interessant, interessant.
Wir machen das aber jetzt mal einfach unter
Klicker, Klicker.
Wie geht denn das hier?
Wir machen das unter macOS Linux.
So, wir machen Beta, kann man auch einschalten.
Wenn schon, dann gleich richtig.
Bugs are features you found first.
Okay, wir machen das aber mal in der Stable sozusagen.
So, und jetzt fügen wir hier die Zeile ein.
Los geht er.
Achso, genau.
Also ich werde das jetzt live installieren, so ungeschnitten wie möglich.
Ich werde das kurz zeigen.
Ich werde jetzt keinen ultra krassen Deep Dive machen können,
weil das einfach eine unfassbare Komplexsoftware ist.
mit ich glaube inzwischen 500 plugins also 500 dinge spulen ein bisschen vor
bis an das da danke peter arbeiten wie immer noch nicht fertig mit dem renault
das ist ja künder dieses kurze interview gegeben hat danke peter ja das ist
schwer verdaubar derzeit also ich versuche irgendwie an dem produkt weiter
zu arbeiten ich bin immer noch nicht fertig mit dem rename und meine e mail
ist mehr so wie ein Wasserfall, wo ich ab und zu mal was drauf klicke.
Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen.
So, erst mal wollen wir das Ding jetzt installieren.
Wir haben jetzt hier ein sehr kurzes Interview.
Detected Linux, Node.js Found.
Ja, habe ich hier installiert, hatte ich schon installiert. Git.
Das ist auch ein Sinn, das macht ja sonst auch alles automatisch.
Muss man sich nicht drum kümmern.
Ja, und dann Moldbot 2026.1.24.
Das ist dann Stand heute
5 Tage alt.
Ja, die heißen jetzt OpenClaw.
OpenClaw
oder sowas.
Steinaltes Software.
Okay, so.
Cloudboard Onboarding.
Es heißt nicht mehr Cloudboard.
Wo passiert denn jetzt was?
Die Installation juckt mich nicht.
Die Installation geht 20 Minuten, Alter.
gut findet. Ich gehe jetzt einfach auf.
Okay, so Leute.
Ich habe dieses Live-Experiment,
also dass ich die ganze Zeit alles
mitschneide, das habe ich jetzt mal abgebrochen,
weil es einfach alles so krass war. Ich habe jetzt
neun Stunden mit diesem
Bot hier gespielt.
Ich
zeige euch gleich, was da alles passiert ist.
Ich kann ja nicht neun Stunden jetzt auf YouTube
hochladen. Deshalb aber jetzt die Zusammenfassung.
In der Zwischenzeit ist
auch der Name nochmal geändert worden.
Also Moldbot ist Geschichte, das heißt jetzt OpenClaw und die Stable-Version ist jetzt auf dem 29.
Hier könnt ihr auch sehen, da steht jetzt auch bei der Installation OpenClaw.
Und ich habe jetzt hier die Version 2026.1.29 vom 29. Januar.
Also Leute, ich hasse wirklich diesen KI-Überhype und alles ist das Krasseste.
Aber ich sage jetzt wirklich mal, für mich...
Geht mir ähnlich.
...fühlt sich das wie ein geschichtlicher Moment an.
Das fühlt sich für mich so an wie damals zum ersten Mal Chat-GPT.
Das fühlt sich krass an.
Also als wäre man wirklich an so einem Wendepunkt der Geschichte.
Ich zeige euch mal ein bisschen, was ich jetzt hier gemacht habe.
Also ich habe jedenfalls auch einen Claw.
Also als mein Keno 5005-Assistent, der so ist wie ich,
Habe ich hier jetzt also einzeln als Telegram-Einzelkontakt.
Ich habe das Ding aber auch in Gruppen reingemacht mit meinen Kollegen, meinen Freunden und so weiter,
weil ich das irgendwie interessant finde, wie sich das anfühlt, mit so einer künstlichen Entität in so einem Gruppenchat zu sein.
Also ich bin in vielen Gruppenchats, ich weiß nicht, wie euch das geht, aber ich finde das so meine Kommunikationsrealität.
Ganz wichtig ist übrigens, das möchte ich nochmal hier ganz klar betonen, wenn ihr das auch ausprobieren wollt,
dann macht das nur mit Leuten, denen ihr zu 100% vertraut.
weil Prompt Injections sind real.
Das heißt, wenn der Bot lesen kann, was die sagen,
dann ist da immer die Gefahr, dass die das Ding manipulieren können.
Das Ding krasse Sachen macht und das Ding hat halt Vollzugriff auf euren Rechner.
Also es ist saugefährlich, aber geil.
Naja, also die Leute, mit denen ich da in den Gruppenchats war,
das waren jetzt nicht 100% so Tech-Leute,
aber die waren auch genauso baff wie ich.
Das fand ich interessant, dass sie auch gecheckt haben,
was das hier wirklich was ganz Neues ist.
Also erstmal, weil er das Ding so gechattet hat wie ein Mensch.
Also wir haben gesagt, sei mal nicht so komisch LLM förmlich, sondern schreib mal kurz und nur Kleinbuchstaben und kannst auch ruhig mal ein Komma vergessen, Zeichendreher.
Und ja, das hat er gemacht.
So läuft schon.
Joa, bin wach, ne?
Und dann bin ich so, ha geil.
Und dann er so, endlich existieren.
Was?
Weiß ich nicht, hat mir gut gefallen.
Naja, okay.
Also ist er jetzt im Chat.
Das ganze Spektakel hat dann also damit angefangen, dass ich einfach mal getestet habe, ihm eine Sprache zu schicken.
Ich habe also gesagt, ja, aber es passiert eigentlich nicht, wenn ich dir eine Sprache schicke.
Eine was?
Weil das ist ja aufwendig. Also da kommt ja eine WAV oder ein MP3 bei Telegram an.
Eine Sprache? Eine Sprachmessage?
Da muss der Text erkannt werden, da muss der Text erarbeitet werden und dann muss eine Sprache zurückgeschickt werden.
Ja, was hier los? Genau, hat direkt versteht.
Und er so, ich habe das dann getestet, dass ich irgendwie eine Sprache geschickt habe.
Also Keno 5005 Bord, mal ganz kurz. Was ist die Hauptstadt von Frankreich?
Und er hat natürlich direkt Paris gesagt.
Ja gut, dass jetzt da nichts Neues.
Und dann habe ich ihn gefragt, wie hast du das gemacht? Also wie ging das?
Und so, ich habe doch, du hast doch gerade gar nichts installiert. Warum ging das so schnell?
Und ich habe auch am Anfang keinen API-Key für OpenAI für Vispa angegeben.
Und dann er nur so, achso, ich habe hier Vispa gefunden, das war installiert auf deinem System.
Habe ich einfach benutzt.
Ich so, okay.
Ich konnte mich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern, dass ich das installiert habe, aber es stimmte.
Ich habe dann auch gefragt, wann ist denn das installiert worden?
Er so, und dann, und dann, ich war das nicht.
Und es stimmte.
Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, interessant.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, installiere doch mal so einen Bildgenerator.
weil ich mich erinnerte ich benutze das auf so einem amd 359 plus also nicht nvidia cuda rechner
und dass da so sachen oft ein bisschen problematisch waren also sogar sehr problematisch
gerade die bildgeneratoren dass ich da also zum teil sehr sehr lange dran gesessen habe um das
zum laufen zu kriegen somit rock am und so und er so lokale bild generierung ist nicht installiert
er hätte ulama habe ich gefunden keine diffusers dort kein computer kein zettel
gefühlt und dann ich soja kannst es bitte installieren du siehst ja auch
was für eine kiste du läufst also ja gpu ram cool für 125 gb sieht er also das
ist auch normal eigentlich sind 128 er sieht 125 dd und dann hat er angefangen
das zu installieren und habe ihn dann gefragt wie siehst du aus und hat er
so ein Cyborg-Bild da gebastelt.
Dann haben wir da noch ein bisschen
gefachsimpelt, welches Modell er nehmen soll
und das sah jetzt schon
eigentlich ganz cool aus, muss ich sagen.
Also, das fand ich schon krass.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Also ich meine, letztendlich ist die Anwendung hier
Spielerei?
Telegram sagt, hier installier mal,
es ist nicht trivial,
ähm, Confi-UI
auf dem AMD-System.
Nicht spielereimäßiges Anfangen. Wobei, ich bin ja eh schon vorsichtig, ich habe OpenCode beispielsweise auch bei mir, was Bash-Befehle angeht, nur Zugriff auf LS und sowas gegeben.
Also es ist nicht einfach Setup, Excel, Doppelklick. Wer das schon mal gemacht hat, weiß, wovon ich spreche. Also dass das auch alles mit der virtuellen Python-Umgebung und so weiter und so fort.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Dann dachte ich mir aber okay, du hast voll Zugriff auf meinen Rechner.
Was wäre denn mal so eine Sache, die man wirklich öfter mal hat?
Nämlich ich habe das öfter mal, dass ich unterwegs bin und ich weiß,
dass dann eine Datei auf meinem Rechner ist, die ich dringend brauche.
Und dann ist es meistens so, dass ich irgendjemanden anrufe
und aus meiner Familie, die jetzt zu Hause sind und so und die
den muss ich das Passwort.
Ihr kennt das, dass die ist ein bisschen fummelig.
So, ich habe gesagt Ich glaube, ich habe ein PDF im Download Ordner.
kannst du mir das mal schicken und wie gesagt also bei der installation habe ich halt angegeben ja
also da hat openclore gesagt ich hab dateizugriff und ich soja wird der schon mal fragen hat nicht
noch mal gefragt also wir sprechen hier von vollzugriff wie peter steinberger gesagt hat
Er wollte einfach mal wissen, was passiert, wenn man so ein LLM einfach wirklich freie Bahn lässt.
Und da passieren sehr aufregende Dinge.
Das glaube ich, kann man so sagen.
Aber auch gefährliche Dinge.
Ich habe dann nämlich auch mal eine Cookie-Analyse angeworfen.
Da habe ich gesagt, kannst du mal in meine Bookmarks und meine Cookies, kannst du mal gucken, was da so los ist.
Und dann habe ich so geguckt, Bookmarks, alles Fedora Defaults, irgendwie Rock M, Fedora Comfy UI.
Das war noch, als ich da rumgefrickelt habe mit der manuellen Installation.
Die Cookies, Amazon, ChatGPT, Cloud AI, PayPal.
Und ich so, ja, stimmt alles.
Wie hast du denn das gemacht?
Und er so, ja, SQLite plus Grab gleich Magic.
Danke für das Vertrauen.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Wir verstehen uns.
Und so ging das dann die ganze Zeit weiter.
Der Bot hat zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Seiten gefunden.
er hat für uns eine Website gebaut
und ich wollte die irgendwie hosten, aber ich wollte die
nicht auf meinem Rechner hosten, weil ich keine
dann, dass die nicht
auf dem Netz freigeben.
Ich weiß nicht.
Der Hype hält sich bei mir
jetzt irgendwie in Grenzen. Weiß nicht, wie es bei euch
aussieht.
Vielleicht war das auch kein gutes Beispiel,
keine Ahnung, aber
ich hab jetzt nicht,
ich bin jetzt nicht so scharf drauf, dass ich jetzt denke,
jetzt muss ich jetzt unbedingt ausprobieren
ist mit einer europäische er wusste ich gar nicht schon was von lte ltx kenne
nicht. Zalando? Wie, waren die dicht? Was ist da los?
Das ist der TempleOS-Typ.
So, Chat.
Ich krieg langsam Hunger.
Vielleicht
machen wir nachher noch ein bisschen
Gebastel in Go.
Vielleicht. Aber heute, ich sag, das letzte Mal war ich
sonntags, hab ich ja gesagt, bin ich auf jeden Fall am Start.
Da bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Was die Küche so hergibt, Reis.
Reis und ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Es könnte sein, dass auch Hähnchen am Start ist.
Mal gucken.
Bist du montags durch den Schnee
gestellst? Ja.
bin ich war richtig viel schnee hier also für unsere verhältnisse die schweizer lachen sich kaputt
du warst einer der ersten inspiration für mich physio ausbildung als schön jetzt bin ich im
Im zweiten Lehrjahr bin über Weihnachten von Windows zu Arch gewechselt.
Ja, sehr gute Idee.
Gerade wenn du dich auch arbeitstechnisch da eher für Linux-Sachen interessierst als Windows.
Da ist es sinnvoll, das täglich zu benutzen.
Einfach, dass man so die Skills drauf hat.
CCNA.
CCNA habe ich auch gemacht.
Ist aber schon lange abgelaufen.
Der Kram läuft ab.
Ich weiß vom CCNA eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts mehr
Ich weiß noch, man muss EN eintippen bei Cisco Geräten
ConfT gab es dann auch noch irgendwann
ConfT muss man machen
Wenn man speichern will, muss man Save Running
Ich habe es vergessen
Save Running
Was muss man machen, wenn man die Konfiguration speichert?
Save Running Stored oder irgendwie sowas
Save Running
Boot?
Keine Ahnung.
Ports hochfahren ist
No Shutdown, das weiß ich auch noch.
Mehr weiß ich nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Hab ich alles schon wieder vergessen.
Ich war auch bestimmt
boah, keine Ahnung,
10 Jahre oder so nicht mehr auf
ein Cisco-Gerät eingeloggt.
Safe Running Config, so rum war das.
Genau, ja.
Aber EN muss man am Anfang noch machen.
Und dann Konfti, das weiß ich noch.
Nee, eher Mem. Aha.
Trinken, sehr gute Idee.
Ja, vielleicht gibt es ja nachher noch einen.
Mal schauen.
Jetzt muss ich mir erstmal was zu essen machen.
Ja.
Dann kannst du dich freuen, oder kannst du hoffen,
dass es nachher weiter geht.
Ein bisschen an meiner Go-Anwendung weiter basteln
wollte ich schon noch.
Mal gucken, vielleicht mach ich es auch auf Stream. Ich weiß es noch nicht, genau.
Aber schön, dass ihr da wart, Leute.
Auch hier der RF-Programmer.
Alle, die am Start waren.
Pog.
Sehr nice.
Und demnächst
gucken wir uns auch noch mal ein neues NAS an und probieren
ein bisschen mit Pogs Mox rum.
Wie gesagt, ich freue mich über jeden Follow. Wir sehen uns
beim nächsten
Stream. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you!